man it's been crazy huh yesterday was
pretty wild everybody's yelling at me
it's great got people tweeting up a
storm for those that have didn't hear we
got it got pretty heated in the members
segment
man it was so yesterday we had Ari the
rugged Man and um you know I we worked
it out we hugged it out we got heated
there was some yelling there was some
standing up and slapping stuff and that
was all in the member segment a lot of
people just did not understand what
happened they thought it was on YouTube
and it got deleted it was never on
YouTube it was on timcast.com and that
was the biggest member segment we've
ever had it and I mean like a hundred
times bigger than anything we've had
before which is crazy it's bigger than
Alex Jones and it overloaded our site
but uh it was crazy and we'll talk a
little bit about that in uh in the show
today but I don't like getting carried
away into the drama stuff but I do think
there's so much misinformation already
about what happened and we should talk
about how we felt about how things were
going like what was going through our
minds and stuff it has uh things got
pretty heated but I mean I I don't know
I didn't think I didn't even really
think it was that big of a deal I was
like man wow you know crazy but
apparently a lot of people like like
Daily Dot wrote this ridiculously fake
article great and there's really
something really interesting about what
the Daily Dot wrote they wrote that uh
that I I called R.A a Racist Prick and
then they go on and say that Tim pool is
white and I thought about that and I'm
like
if I'm a quarter Korean you know two
generations of mixed race families but I
am
definitively factually white and I'm
like that would be a really interesting
precedent for their ideology as it
pertains to all mixed race people you
know what I mean but we'll talk more
about this the bigger news is that Nick
Sandman settled his defamation suit with
NBC for a confidential sum which sounds
like it's probably a decent amount of
money might not be as big as many people
think but you know we'll take a look at
that we got President Biden apparently
calling Kamala Harris president
Harris again
we got MSNBC saying Ron desantis's
anti-woke Bill is what is it in
codifying white supremacy or some other
stupid trash
you know man's Friday how about we just
chill have a good time we got a bunch of
people hanging out we're hanging out
with Olivia Rondo how's it going man
you got to pull up your mic
and taco
I'm so happy to be back perfect so what
do you do who are you
um I'm Olivia Rondo I'm a journalist and
I consider myself to gotta get the
microphone okay we're here right up I'm
turning you up all right all right all
right journalist and Liberty activist
you may have seen me
um
on Kennedy on Fox Business a lot you may
have seen me on there or an HBO talk
show called pause with Sam J I was also
on there this year
all right sweet
thanks for coming thank you you were
here before too though we got Shane
Cashman what's up I'm uh the writer and
host of tales from the inverted world we
just put out our first book volume one
closing close contact with a ghost
simulation Theory look at that there's a
book go down a lot of rabbit holes look
a lot of weird stuff
it was fun I'm happy to have it out so
you can go to uh invertedworldbook.com
and get your copy right now to have it
out this is some someone messaged me and
they're like wow congratulations on
starting a publishing house and I was
like I don't know is that what it is we
are now surprised right I was like I was
like hey Shane you make a book you're
like yeah I'm like all right
yeah yeah oh and then there's Luke and
uh surprise look I'm still here look
apologize to me a couple times I was
like because because like people don't
understand like I I knew Ari for like a
number of years now and I'm like this
would be a great opportunity for
everyone to come together and to talk
and I thought it was going to go a lot
different than it would and yeah it was
it was a little crazy I know I did talk
about uh you know starting a fight club
at the house but but that kind of
escalated really quickly it was a joke
it was a joke but Luke is talking about
bringing like a personal trainer for
people yeah no no I did it no no I did I
hired a jiu jitsu trainer for the house
it's in the latest Vlog you could
actually watch our latest kind of uh
exercise everyone in the house was
participating in we're going to be doing
this weekly and now uh practicing and
studying Jiu Jitsu in the house not
because of what happened last night but
because this was an initiative that we
talked about doing for a very long time
now we're doing it so I'm very excited
about that I'm already working on I'm
not that guy merch
sarcastically obviously but anyway
today's merch that I'm wearing right now
is I would say right on the nose if you
get it you get it some people will not
understand it but if you will it sends a
very strong political message and you
could get yours on the
bestpoliticalshirts.com and then when
you do you support me thanks so much for
having me uh and uh yeah that was
wildlife
it was like Thanksgiving dinner it was
in my house it was I thought it was I
thought it was a really really good show
I think what people don't realize is you
gotta have people who disagree with you
you can't just of course and and not
everybody's gonna
articulate the way you it's it's not
going to be some like two smart people
you know or intellect Intelligentsia
types just sitting there being like well
I humbly disagree sir like sometimes
like people just saying you're wrong I
disagree I think you're dumb I think
you're a liar this is the way things
going do you think he'll walk away and
question how he acted yesterday and like
think differently about his uh his
perception of the world I don't know I
don't know I hope so either I do I I I I
look man I think he's racist you know
but we'll talk about this because we got
a segment that talks a little bit we got
a couple segments actually talking about
this and I'll just I'll just say one
thing on this before we get started it
was weird to me that my stance was when
I was little my family got my family
home was was attacked by White
supremacists and he the guy who's
supposed to be opposing racism was was
the one laughing about that and saying
so what I don't care so I'm like you
really don't care like how is it that
I'm the guy saying white supremacists
are bad and he was the one laughing
saying you know what I mean but we
disagree we disagree and that's that's
fine I don't got any beef you know I
disagree with them anyway Lydia is here
yeah I'm also here it is true that you
have to meet people where they are and
they're not always going to articulate
in the way that you would like them to I
do love that we're able to bring people
on and have these challenging
conversations because I don't know that
people believe that people really think
this and people like him do so it's
worth learning about and continuing to
Grapple with yes now before we get
started we have an awesome sponsor today
this is the light bug go to
l-y-t-e-bug.com and you can get the
light bug it is a solar powered or USB
charged flood light and that's really
what it is it's that simple It's amazing
And you can actually use it as a USB
power bank for your USB devices so this
is it comes it comes with two big
batteries interestingly though you can
pull the batteries out and actually put
in different kinds of batteries this
really is a brilliant emergency light
device so if you want to check one out
go to
lytebug.com you get 66 percent off today
and if you use the promo code timcast20
you get an additional I believe 20 off
dimps20 they say it is solar powered
charging Bank you can use as a for your
phone and USB devices it's great for
outdoor and emergency situations such as
car repair fishing camping Etc
adjustable bracket on the back you can
actually prop it's a solar panel you can
actually use it as a stand and all that
stuff battery indicator tells you 33 66
and 100 percent check it out at
lightbug.com and use promo code
timcast20 and don't forget as Shane
mentioned you can go to
invertedworldbook.com and pick up your
copy of timcast media's first book first
of many Shane's already got plans and
working on the next book which is
amazing and I think the next one is
going to be even better but you can pick
up Tales from the inverted World close
contact with ghosts UFOs serial killers
and simulation Theory volume one in
paperback at
invertedworldbook.com and become a
member at timcast.com help support our
work directly and we greatly appreciate
it if you want to see exactly what
happened in the episode yesterday which
you know everybody was going nuts about
I was trending on Twitter it was nuts um
that's the latest members only segment
with ra the rugged Man and you can check
it out and make you think for yourself
decide for yourself how you feel about
it but that was the biggest members only
segment we've ever had in less than in
about 20 in less than 24 hours over a
thousand comments on it the views there
were so much there was so much
interaction on it that it overloaded our
site and we have like Hefty servers so
check that stuff out but don't forget to
like this video subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends let's talk about this first
story ah the media
the fake news Nick salmon settles
defamations with NBC for confidential
some another slanted liberal news outlet
has felt the sting of Justice according
to NewsBusters in a Friday evening tweet
from the defamed man himself former
Covington high school student Nicholas
salmon announced that he had settled his
defamation suit with NBC news for an
undisclosed amount of money with little
Fanfare Sandman posted the Tweet reading
at this time I would like to release
that NBC and I have reached a settlement
the terms are confidential Sandman sued
NBC for over 250 million dollars I don't
I do not think he got anywhere near that
but I certainly think this kid is going
to be pretty comfortable now I bring
this up and that and that's the gist of
this story many of us know the history
of of Nick Sandman and the Covington
kids but I wanna I wanna wrap this back
into kind of the uh the current
situation around what happened on this
show and everything and just say you
know when I'm having a conversation with
someone and they're obstinate but their
world view is based on media lies you
need to look at the Nick salmon case you
need to look at the jussie Smollett case
you need to look at Russia gate and you
can start to understand why these people
are trapped in this broken worldview
that makes no sense yeah or even the
Iraq war or the banker bailout I mean
there's so many things that the
corporate media you know spread lies
about that were completely absolutely
not true at all so this is this sad man
cases is a very important case because
this is his third win he has six
lawsuits in total one of the first major
wins was of course against CNN that now
I think should have a reputation of
hurting children I think there's an
epidemic make literally going on I'm
seeing it hurting children in so many
unspeakable ways Veritas released the
name yes yes yes and then there's a
number of producers there's also Jack
besobic who claims that CNN was hiring
this first producer that did unspeakable
things to children for over a year
knowing that the FBI had data on him
that he was doing very illegal things to
Children again family friendly show here
so we're not going to be talking about
that but but again CNN there's an
epidemic going around and it's not good
for children CNN has two producers but
they're two high-level producers it was
a guy working with Cuomo and a guy
working with Tapper
that to me right away I'm not gonna come
I wouldn't I wouldn't say that's enough
for me to be like clearly CNN as a
gigantic can you know crazy but I would
be like I think it's time to actually do
a deep investigation maybe maybe
subpoena some some devices because if
you've got two in this short amount of
time that just popped out and they're
both at the top level shows I think CNN
I think that law enforcement I want to
start asking questions about who's
working there what they're doing Tim two
that we know about right that's what I
mean don't we know about and then that's
what I'm saying and then and then I was
making a reference to of course Sandman
because Sandman also sued CNN and won
successfully after CNN also hurt him
when he was a child so again I was being
a little hyperbolical sensationalistic
there but uh I'm happy to see Sandman
get the settlement I would kind of want
to see like a apology from the outlets
you know I wanted to come out and be
like we broke your world view we
fractured reality and we're taking
account but it'll never happen we lied
we slandered a literal child we slanted
a teenager for political propaganda
purposes but you know here's some money
on the side yeah and only to you're not
going to get anything satisfactory the
LIE travels halfway around the world
before the truth can strap on his boots
yeah yeah because there's people still
roaming the world who believe in the
false reality from the beginning like
The Rittenhouse thing I mean that's I
believe what was the Catalyst for what
happened last night for sure we had a
dude here who was adamant in his belief
about a false reality yeah and it's
crazy I mean I think collectivism versus
individualism plays a huge role in all
of this stuff but I think as I often say
it's not left versus right you know it
it doesn't make sense like vosh for
instance he had a segment with a decent
take on what happened the other day but
he called me a conservative and and by
Nature then if you're conservative
you're racist and then I literally say
abolish the police on the clip and he's
like and he goes thank you Tim and I'm
like I don't understand how you could
claim and there's anything conservative
about wanting to abolish the place
libertarian Anarchist or whatever but
that's why I often say that what's
really going on which is exemplified by
the by the Sandman thing is Sandman
Sandman thing there there are the people
who know who are Discerning who are
looking for facts and evidence and there
are the people who don't and just
believe narratives and so when it comes
to Cal Rittenhouse they they are still
wrong to this day when it came to Nick
Sandman Bill Maher came out a week after
the retractions and said BS info and I
was like bill you do you had a week yeah
yeah I I he's getting sued too isn't he
oh I don't know I bill look man I like
Bill Maher for you know because because
he pushes back on this stuff but it's
like Bill Maher is so close to getting
his head out of the sand he's so close
but he's not quite there I love seeing
his audience be hesitant to clap
sometimes yeah that's one of the best
things but they're scared not hesitant
they're scared and terrified because he
sometimes like he's he's not the best
but but sometimes he drops a truth bomb
that that wakes everyone up being like
wait wait wait hold on he's supposed to
be telling us the narrative we're
supposed to clap you know when the sign
tells us to clap and they're like oh is
this acceptable and they're kind of
looking around here because he he does
land some punches but a lot of the times
he does a lot of bidding for the
establishment if any one of these people
just read
Bill Maher doesn't yes that's why when
it came to like critical race Theory
stuff Bill Maher was kind of like well
if they're teaching kids this that's bad
if they're teaching that then it's good
and it's like Bill why don't you just
read one article and you can say it's
bad but what ends up happening is you
know a big portion of what we end up
fighting over especially yesterday was
critical race Theory being banned in
schools is stopping the teaching of
racism it's like that's that's not at
all what any of us are upset about or
worried about but that's what they hear
on TV people like Bill Maher who are
supposed to be the opposition
regurgitate that talking point from Bad
actors and then they think we're the
ones who are making it up when we you
know when it came to Kyle Rittenhouse
that's what really kicked off everything
the other day I'm like we've had seven
different witnesses to what happened
with Kyle renas on this show I do not
base my opinions off of like watching a
random Twitter video from you know some
leftist Progressive I was like I want to
see the people who are there tell me
what happened and then we get that we
get that information and I base my
opinions off that but if you base your
opinions off of how CNN named it then
you're going to be getting sued when you
talk smack against people like Nick
salmon
absolutely and the facts matter here and
your words matter and that's why you
should always be careful and if you you
know if you make a mistake you should
issue a correction A lot of these
newspapers a lot of these news
organizations don't have anything
holding them accountable they publish a
retraction maybe on page 17 maybe in a
little byline but the the build up
especially when it came to the war in
Iraq when it came to russiagate had huge
impacts on our daily lives that impacted
us negatively that hurt people that
killed people that literally created
some of the worst scenarios that
destroyed any elements of Truth and
honesty in our society and and they were
still never held responsible for a lot
of those bigger lies so it's good to see
on a personal level some accountability
but we still have to remember by and
large the corporate media has a long
criminal past with some very disgusting
behavior that they still should be held
responsible for but they haven't I think
you know Ian says this a lot he's not
here tonight he's on vacation for the
holidays but he says a lot of all of
this started breaking apart when 9 11
happened I think he's right I think you
know after 9 11 you get uh the Patriot
Act you get the Iraq War the war in
Afghanistan you you you got this this
Matrix narrative that started it it just
started changing things and then you get
I I mean to be completely honest it may
have actually even been the 2000
election how contentious it was but I
think the authoritarianism that popped
out of after 9 11 really changed how how
we we live in work and View Law
Enforcement authorities then you get
this this cultural back and forth it
escalates to the point where we end up
with how social media I talk I talk
about how social media manipulation
became a big prominent thing but I
believe that there was a major like
fracture in the timeline around 9 11.
yeah 911 brought in that fear that
translated to political power for the
intelligence agencies and the government
secret agencies that profited off of it
in so many different ways whether it was
insider trading I don't want to get into
the nitty-gritty I don't want to get
into the details here but I would argue
that what happened and after 9 11 was
trauma-based mind control literally
people were shown thousands of people
dying all at once and then blaming other
people in other countries who had
nothing to do with it saying they did it
they did it they killed your friends
they killed your family emerged they
could kill you next and they used that
fear that psychological warfare against
the general public to say just give us a
little bit of your rights just give us a
little bit of your free uh privacy and
of course it started with you know just
reasonable asks and then it became more
unreasonable more crazy more Sinister to
the point where now the NSA knows almost
every little thing you do they track
trace and database or activities there's
a secret social credit score that no one
even wants to talk about we're living in
a database now where you need government
permission to go to the supermarket in
some places in the United States and
that is absolutely insane Draconian and
crazy and it all started
I would argue some people would argue it
started even way before that but I think
the the larger kind of uh Snowball
Effect started on not 11 and it kept
rolling in this kind of trajectory of
just give up your rights for your
greater good for the benefit of humanity
no no no no no no no that's the biggest
lie sold to people all throughout
history and it always leads to tyranny
and I think that's where where we're at
right now I talked about
grown up after 9 11. I'm gonna date
myself here I was eight months old on my
line okay so I grew up I didn't know a
time before the Patriot Act I didn't
know a time before TSA I didn't know
time before Department of Homeland
Security you know I grew up my dad
worked for the Department of Homeland
Security so I grew up just very
comfortable with authoritarianism with
tyranny
um I didn't understand like even um like
you know back before 9 11 you can like
walk up to the gate with your family to
you know drop them off I thought that
was a movie Trope I didn't know that was
an actual thing until I was like in at
least middle school or high school and I
actually learned about TSA and 911 and
so I think we have to really Target
Zoomers because I'm a Zoomer I know how
to talk to Zoomers and and actually like
really drill this into their minds
because they don't even realize how
comfortable with the government
overreaching their lot like they don't
they just don't even understand it it
took a long time for me to understand
and I still can't even understand
because I don't I don't know what it was
like before yeah and I can learn about
it I could try to educate myself about
it but that's something we we really
need to talk more about with the younger
generation I think this is what I've
I've been saying about with the
metaverse that the younger Generations
like the kids born today are going to
grow up into the metaverse and be like I
don't know a world without it like
you're saying you don't know the world
before all this stuff that's what's
going to happen they're doing an
increment at a time these these cronies
they stay in office for 80 you know for
60 years or whatever and then they
Implement that as Generations move on 50
years people are going to be
microchipped and they're going to be
like I don't know a world without the
neural link I I've only ever known the
metaverse the metaverse will be there
for the next lockdown but you don't need
a high social credit score to go to the
supermarket you don't need to pledge
allegiance to the corporate technocratic
overlords before buying your Snapple
when they when they first locked
everybody down when we were in New
Jersey they said don't go outside unless
you absolutely have to and so you they
weren't going to arrest you or ticket
you but they were like stay-at-home
orders so I had you know in our backyard
we had big open space I put on the
Oculus and I went to go they have a
Google Maps app where you can go all
over the place that's fun and the
craziest thing was you know where I went
you know where I went when I put on
those those Oculus in New Jersey your
neighborhood here yeah oh here yeah I
went here with Harper's Ferry and I I
crossed the bridge and I was going
through the neighborhood and then we
started trying to figure out where to go
and I was like let's go here
so I was actually wearing the headset
and you can like look around on Google
Maps and like move forward you click and
you move forward and it was crazy to me
that everybody's I'm like everybody's
locked in these cubicles and they're
little garbage little Studios I bet tons
of people have this and they use it to
like calm down yeah one of the craziest
things about it and I think we're going
here if I I'm sure a lot of you guys
have the Oculus there's a theater mode
where you put them on and you turn on a
movie and it you it's a giant theater
screen in front of you and you can move
your head and this there's a movie
theater right in front of you when
you're watching movies and the sound
coming in your ears perfectly that's
where we're going that's great you're
gonna and it's gonna be they're doing
linked you know things now like
experiences
you're going to be sitting in your chair
and you're you know 200 square foot
bachelor pad I need to correct you
you're going to be in your pod you're
going to be in your pod this is like I
will not be in the pot I will not eat
the bugs I will not watch movies on the
Oculus are those the pods they're 3D
printing in Switzerland
um yeah there's also a lot of maybe
yeah but but you'll you'll like hey guys
you want to go to the movies and you'll
put on your Oculus you'll go into the
metaverse and you'll be like watching
Spider-Man with your friends sitting
next to you and you'll look to your left
and you'll see their little like carrot
Avatar and the guy in front of you is
like a rabbit and the guy behind him is
a duck and then someone's a a caricature
of you know Mickey Mouse or something I
think you know a lot of people say the
Matrix is a documentary for for a very
specific reason because when you look at
essentially what they're calling for
especially with the world economic Forum
with a lot of very powerful globalists
living in a pod being connected to the
virtual Road uh virtual world and then
having paced bug paste and bug juice and
this artificially GMO created paste
given to you as as artificial meat that
that's literally you know what was
happening in The Matrix with people in
their little pods being used as bubbles
being used as batteries literally being
plugged into the virtual world and I
think someone probably someone like top
tier globalist either inspired the
Matrix or saw the Matrix and was like I
want that we're going to make that
happen what a dream yes yeah you'll have
nothing in the real world but everything
in the metaverse exactly yeah you all
nothing and you'll be happy you'll have
no privacy and and that's essentially
what they were calling for they deleted
uh that article so people can't pull it
up right now but when you look at the
article when you look at a lot of their
papers that they released they
essentially write the blueprint for what
could be described as the Matrix as you
living in a pod being their source of
energy their their battery for their own
personal enjoyment and benefit living in
their world that they fully control and
it's I feel like the first seat of that
is Media manipulation right that's why
we joke about how these people are in a
cult they're they're in the Matrix like
now eventually they're going to be in
The Matrix and they're gonna gleefully
clap and cheer as they enter it which
people told us in the super chats that's
that's actually Matrix Canon and I guess
the animatrix humans chose to Enter the
Matrix in exchange for a paradise but
then the robots were like it doesn't
work people don't want it and then like
switched it up on them whoa let's let's
talk about MSNBC let's keep it going
with the fake news we got this from
NewsBusters another story insane MSNBC
host thinks DeSantis wants to codify
white supremacy by Banning critical race
Theory MSNBC is known for its insane and
vile commentary which occurs on almost
daily basis but this one might be the
craziest comments this week during a
segment on msnbc's the beat with Ari
melber philan host Jason Johnson
discussed Governor Ron DeSantis his
support of a bill that would ban
critical race theory in public schools
Johnson claimed the proposed legislation
titled stop woke Act is desantis's new
effort to codify white supremacy for
political gain what does white supremacy
mean see this was one of the the big
issues that occurred one of the points
of contention for the episode we did
with uh with R.A the rugged Man was that
I don't think even he knows his own
definition of white supremacy right and
a lot of people don't typically the
cultural right believes white supremacy
to mean
someone who believes they are
genetically Superior based on their race
or the ideology of that but the leftists
critical race theorists believe white
supremacy literally just means dominant
culture so when the left says white
supremacy they're referring to the fact
that most people in this country are
white that's it so they'll say things
like uh when they say you know Hollywood
is is a white supremacist Institution
what people on the right here is that
they're accusing people in Hollywood of
believing they're genetically Superior
based on a race what the left is saying
is that it's a it's an institution
created by white people that mostly
benefits the majority uh the the largest
you know race like majority race in the
country because of this you end up with
stories like this they make no sense so
when uh so so I would argue this if you
take away the word white supremacy and
replace it for what they're actually
saying and say that um Jason Johnson
said the stopwoke ACT is desensis new
effort to codify
traditional American culture for
political gain it's like oh
yeah maybe huh I mean sure I don't know
it doesn't sound nearly as insane well I
think definitions matter here and that's
why in yesterday's interview I was like
wait what do you mean by this what is
your understanding of this because I
think there was a disconnect with what
we thought the words mean and when it
comes to the word white supremacy it has
been used and abused to such a silly
level that I feel like in some instances
it's losing it's it's meaning it's
losing its power because it rained and
MSNBC was freaking out saying it's white
supremacy that caused it to rain uh I'm
being facetious here but but they
literally almost blame everything
underneath the sun if you're going on
nature hikes that's white supremacy
native going out to Nature is white
supremacy and I'm like you're devaluing
this word and this meaning so for MSNBC
to say this as hyperbolic as they are
it's like okay what are you really
trying to say here because you
bastardize the language they're zombies
they're zombies zombies and zombie
alords that was I I love that
conversation we had when Ian was here I
was like because NPC zombies kind of
interchangeable and then I mentioned
well some of these people know they're
lying but I think the people at MSNBC
who are saying this stuff are just
mindlessly repeating the words but there
are people who know they're changing the
definition of the words to manipulate
people into joining their cult ideology
and so I asked are zombies evil and I
think Ian first said no he's like no no
you know they're neutral or whatever and
then and then we looked up or actually
no I think he said zombies are evil in
the in the official dungeon to Dragon
zombies are evil so even if you're
mindless like this is the perfect
example of the banality of evil
mindlessly going all going along with
evil I'm sorry that makes you evil you
know what I mean yeah Luke you're
totally right the definition changing
and then they repeat the words that are
not they're not they don't mean anything
anymore I'm calling this the death of
language that's how you create multiple
realities because there's a whole group
of people operating in certain
definitions there's another group of
people operating in different
definitions like the the the guy drove
the car through the people to Christmas
parade we saw a lot of tweets and
headlines that was a car that drove
through the SUV you're killing language
there right it was an accident but if it
was someone else who looked differently
they would sensationalize that to make
it very specific to make it you know you
afraid of that it's almost as if it's
orwellian as we're going through double
speak which I I heard of that yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and I think that's
you could we could relate to that since
of course even scientific definitions of
herd immunity vaccines are being changed
right in front of our eyes when it meant
something else previously before and I
think the same thing is happening with
white supremacy uh where race has
changed that went from being just
prejudiced against somebody because of
their race to being about powers and
systems and oppression and Prejudice and
white people are or black people can't
be racist and white people are only they
can only just have prejudice against
black face of white supremacists yeah I
mean it just it has no meaning it's
watered down and then but it's like
crazy that these audiences is either
love that they're changing the
definition or don't realize it but
either way it's the same end result and
it's evil there's there a couple a
couple of the issues you know uh and and
I gotta say like we all really want to
talk about what happened last night but
it really was a good example of the
culture war and and what happens
afterwards so one of the things that
happened afterwards is vosh we've had my
shop a couple times he's um he's made
progress I I have great respect when he
first came on the show he called me Far
Right yesterday or I or maybe it's
earlier today he called me a
conservative so he's moving me closer to
the middle that's almost a liberal
almost I'm getting close to being a
Centrist but he actually defended me he
he actually he made a really good point
he said he said something like let's be
real guys if this was any other mixed
race person explaining the experience
racism and a white person was laughing
in their face and insulting them you
would be on that person's side but
because it's Tim Poole you want to be
mad at him and I was like Wow and and
then watch around to say Temple is a
conservative and then of course that
means he's racist and I was like come on
come on so close you're so close and
then I go and then and then he plays he
presses play and I go I want to abolish
the police and he goes thank you Tim and
I'm like bro the problem is everybody
shared one small clip so the The
Narrative becomes something untethered
to reality if any one of these people
would just actually take their heads out
of the sand and consume media to better
understand it then a lot of this might
stop happening but the other issue is
when it came to the actual conversation
with with uh you know R.A
many of these people don't agree that he
is being racist because in their new
moral framework or lack thereof
white people are allowed to insult
people who are not white and that's not
racism so long as their ideology is in
line with the tribe or the cult so when
they say racist what they're really
saying is deviant they're they're saying
you're a deviant you're a deviant so
when I call him a deviant people go no
he's not he's perfectly in line with
wokeness so to them they're hearing me
basically like they don't hear the word
racist the way we do when when I say to
him you're a racist I'm saying you
literally said that you would judge
someone based on the content uh you
judge someone on the color of their skin
to me you're being racist when you
discriminate against someone on their
race to them racist just means you are a
deviant from our from our ideology if
you were a media darling and he was and
Aria was in here with a mega hat and he
accused to even laugh at you they would
have said Tim Poole you know Asian Asian
podcaster you know to make sure oh yeah
we all knew he's a victim let me let me
explain something that you know one of
the jokes that we make on the show every
so often is that blonde hair blue-eyed
lucrid Kowski is a person of color and
literal second generation mixed race
temple is white I'm like I don't even
know what is going on in their brains
like but but I I think it's fair to say
what they're really saying is deviant
when they say racist or white
supremacists he brought up this point
would you happen to have the old
definition and the new definition by any
chance because I think I saw something
online I don't know where to look racism
of the term racism
um not the I mean
I generally believe that it's just hate
or Prejudice because of somebody's race
or skin color now I think at least one
dictionary and just in many schools have
thought like in Academia you'll see the
definition be changed to it's uh it's
like it's Prejudice and Prejudice plus
power so black people can't be racist
because they can be prejudiced but they
don't have power in today's white
supremacist racist system so black
people therefore can't be racist and
white people can't be victims of racism
because they have the power and the
Prejudice so they're just nothing
nothing just comes at them and and then
Luke isn't white because Slavic people
experience oppression and Asian people
in America are white because they have
high incomes on average so they've
turned white into an ideology it's a
boogeyman well if you look at history
history is filled with oppression
whether you're you're Chinese or
Japanese or Korean or polish
um you look you know people have been
screwed over throughout historically but
but you know do you see people
leveraging that for their own kind of
purposes or excuses is to me it's it's
it's it's like thinking low of somebody
and and it's thinking low of yourself
and I think some of it is done
deliberately this is just my perspective
I might be wrong someone might be might
might be able to convince me that I'm
wrong but but for me I think something
that really does oppress people is
saying continually you're oppressed
you're oppressed you're oppressed and
when you keep putting that into
someone's mind they create an identity
that is oppressed that does believe that
they have lack of opportunities and that
kind of mindset that kind of idea that
kind of larger Consciousness that you're
putting out there to your regular life
that you're manifesting that you're
creating is creating that of of of lack
of of being the victim I want to chase
this deviant idea too because there was
some something else that came up
yesterday in the show that exemplifies
this when I was trying to explain a very
that that you know this world is
comprised of many people with different
World Views Ra's response was I said
your world view he said yeah reality
and so when he so I here's what I think
happens he believes he's in the Moral
Majority he believes that his ideas are
represented by most people or that you
know he's on the side of good or
whatever
but a lot of these people don't seem to
realize that when you have you know 80
million people voting one way and 80
million people voting the other
certainly there are two distinct you
know perceptions or I should say
overarching perceptions so for me when I
started getting into into this work and
I mean just doing journalism in general
I remember
um I went out during Occupy Wall Street
there was a pro-life rally at the
federal building by Wall Street by the
by the stock exchange and we went and we
saw these people and we saw them waving
their flags and I listened to what they
said and my attitude's always been like
if we're talking about helping the
working class that means recognizing
that half the working class are
conservative and half are you know left
or whatever and that means we really
need to understand where people are in
general not just one side of things but
too many of these people think 99 of the
country is them and there's this weird
deviant group of people so when they say
you're a racist they're saying you are
not in line with the Moral Majority
which is us our our ideology is correct
and then when I try and point something
out like there are 80 million people who
who roll the other direction from you
and don't agree with you they just they
say that's not true they don't believe
it they reject that or they say well
those people are wrong and crazy or
grifters or liars and it's like that
that's why you'll often hear people say
that the right things the left is
misguided to the left thinks the right
is evil I think that's starting to
change now with many on the right many
and and the funny thing too is the right
is not just right wing it's also
comprised of the center like if you
actually look at Pew's research on this
which is hilarious the stressed sideline
they call it apolitical individuals lean
right and it's because the left has gone
off the rails when you look at that
axios poll we looked at last week that
shows young Democrats are overwhelmingly
antagonistic based on on politics and
not conservatives we can see whatever is
happening it's happening as an effect of
modern left culture or whatever and I
think it's working brilliantly to the
benefit of the special interests that
really kind of pull the strings that
really kind of set the new stories that
set the agenda that set the narrative
because let's call a spade a spade here
there there's a lot of things you and
R.A agreed on there's so many things
that the government does that you
weren't happy about it I know I know but
but hold on let me just get to this
point there's so many things you guys
had in common especially with your
visions and your ideas and your beliefs
and and things that you went through
that was outside of the established
narrative but on this point it brought
you two guys towards a very tense angry
moment between each other that's how
powerful and divisive a lot of this
stuff is where even if he could see eye
to eye and a lot of stuff you still
fight each other that's crazy amount of
power and division uh-uh I gotta stop
you there bro when R.A says to me you
think you've got it worse than black
people in this country yeah and I said
no I agree with you I actually did work
on the subject and then he says it again
three times I'm like bro I don't know
how many times I need to tell you I
agree with you on that but for him to
just be like no one is allowed to talk
about racism because of the black
struggle I'm like this dude you cannot
reason with I I literally tell him you
are correct I agree with you critical
race Theory should not be banned in
schools it's just the practice of he
goes okay all right how many times does
he need to say something he goes y'all
called Kyle written us a hero and I said
we never did that and he went okay okay
I'm like how many times do I need to
reach out and say I agree with you I
agree with you I agree with you but he
didn't he he it's like it's it's not
it's it's that's why I'm saying it's
about being a deviant it's about not
being in line with our Orthodoxy so
that's what they're calling you yes by
and large what I was saying you said it
more eloquently and a lot better than I
did because again the worst terms of
agreement but it still led to
confrontation which to me is
mind-boggling of of how they are able to
control the narrative in a way where it
still leads to no understanding and a
fighting and that to me deserves to be
pointed out I but listen I think we all
understood him I think we were all uh
analytical as to think like we analyzed
the things he had been saying he talks
about news in a way where he he didn't
understand things he was talking about
how we didn't know what critical race
theory was and I and I gave him just a
very generalized here's one of the
authors here's what they've stated
here's what they believe because I I
read the stuff and full disclosure when
we had vosh on the first time I was I
was miserable in in trying to break down
what critical race theory was and I I
think vosh made a great point when he
was like you don't know what you're
talking about and I said well my view of
it is the cultural like wokeness and
stuff but you know what I absolutely
owned up to that and said it's a good
point I should not use a phrase that I
have not read the literature on so I
pulled up the book from Kimberly
Crenshaw and I started reading did not
read the whole thing I read it I read
the first few bits of it to understand
the origins of it I read quotes and
comments from Derek Bell I read some
D'Angelo and some even Mexican and I'm
still not going to pretend to be an
expert but for someone to come in here
say these things and for me to be like
which of these authors do you agree with
and him to be like I don't know I don't
know that I have no idea I don't know
anything about it I'm like okay here's a
problem if I'm gonna tell you that
there's some there's a lot of the stuff
we we agree on but no matter how much we
try to come to you to your side and say
we want to rectify this you still just
say you guys are racists you guys are
white supremacists you are bootlickers
there is no there is no coming together
there's no compromise there's no
resolving this bridge
I'll just stress this point again when
I'm literally like you're you are right
and I agree with you and the response
from the other side is I don't care
screw you you're a lying piece of crap
I'm just like all right that's it it's
conflict The Divide is real and it's
very I'm trying to stay positive I met
him but I was going to ask is there
anything that could bridge this divide
is there anything possible I think so I
met a lady yesterday total stranger in
her 70s a nice lady we agreed on Books
and Music and we were there looking at
some stuff and there was another
gentleman there who I don't really know
but she knew and she pulled me to the
side and said he's in he's an
anti-vaxxer and I was like oh I everyone
can do whatever they want I'm okay and
in mind and she kept trying to get
politics out of me and she was trying to
like find labels and how to like
pigeonhole me next right and then uh 30
minutes later she says
I wish every Republican would drop dead
just like that and she was totally fine
it was normal like she could say to a
stranger and I'm like well that's a
horrible thing to say and I was like I
think I think you are putting labels on
too many people and you you're hearing
certain words like that you know he
didn't want the vaccines now he's all
these things maybe he's racist in your
mind a Maga support or whatever and I'm
like if you just take the labels away
and talk to people about the real
problems you'll probably agree on lots
of things like what Tim and R.A were
talking about and then she was like you
know I did have an hour-long
conversation with this man he was very
nice but once he said the vaccine thing
all the alarms went off in her head that
she would hear the buzzwords on CNN and
uh I think if you start to strip away
labels like that's why that when I see
words like woke
I hate words like that I'm so sick of
words like that because it automatically
makes anyone who agrees with woke stuff
um and and who doesn't agree with it
want to fight about it yeah but just
strip away those stupid words I think I
think we use too many bad words like
cancel culture and woke there's a
compulsive need to label people though
people try to do the same thing to me
all the time and even when they find out
what I believe and there's still no
label to put on it so then they get even
more frustrated but I need to know I
think it's getting worse actually the
compulsive needs to label people but I
need to know like how do we combat that
like how do we change the messaging to
work to the point where people don't
feel the need to be like hey like what
do you believe about that and then
immediately assume your political party
or assume everything else it's like gang
members it's like are you a blood are
you a [ __ ]
for real but I really
Luke Luke and I we went to the peace
wall in Northern Ireland and I really
recommend people go to Belfast and look
at the peace wall it it it it will be a
shock to your system and I mentioned
this a lot when I went there when we
were there and there's like on one side
it's pro-israel on the other side is
pro-palestine and I was just I was
confused and I asked this guy who was
there I was like I don't understand like
what is what is the the Irish conflict
have to do with Israel and Palestine and
the dude said whatever whatever idea one
side adopts the other side takes the
opposite stance yeah it's just tribalism
and it's and it's neighbors living next
to each other with huge walls dividing
them literally neighbors rioting and
fighting each other to the point where
they're killing each other and they're
they're neighbors they live in the same
kind of country they kind of have the
same identity they have a different kind
of religious point of view but that
divide is so strong and crazy where they
literally burn Effigies of other
people's
um you know belief systems and and
representatives in celebration in
defiance of the other side so that was a
surreal experience to see that larger
kind of some people call it a festival
that literally leads to marches and
fights and riots in Northern Ireland
which was absolutely crazy too and
that's to see an experience myself
that's just one small area relative to
the rest of the world and this is this
kind of thing is gripping the entire U.S
like you saying the lady said she wished
Republicans would all just drop dead
like I gotta I look I think there's a
lot of really great things to focus on
in terms of you know Freedom gun rights
are being strengthened but there's also
uh you know I'm not trying to be a
downer I do think that freedom and
individualism is actually gaining a lot
of ground in a lot of different ways but
I also think the hyperpolarization is
becoming more and more enraged like like
the way like the story you as you
explained it people are just getting
angry like I don't care I just hate and
that's scary that's the Vic she's a
victim of the corporate press they fed
her fear but it's it's more than that
too I mean so one of the things that RS
at the beginning of the show is that
is that something the effect of
everything is extremely all these media
Outlets are extremely divisive and we're
doing the exact same thing here on the
show and I said you're right I agree we
talk about that when we see MSNBC say
that you know Ron DeSantis is codifying
white supremacy or whatever garbage and
then we criticize them and newsbuster
says they're known for insane vile
commentary and all that stuff yeah we're
sitting here with a bunch of people
listening and they're going to be like I
don't like MSNBC and what they do and
then we're going to get people who are
only going to take small clips of this
show and then do the counter of saying
look at what they're saying they're vile
racist or whatever and all it does is
create Echo Chambers where everyone
hates each other more and more and more
I suppose the one difference is one side
is objectively correct and that side is
whatever this side is and it's not the
right it's not libertarian it's just
literally there are people who are
writing people who are wrong and if you
look at the Jesse Smith story The
Covington kids Nick's Nick salmon stuff
you look at Kyle Rittenhouse you look at
Russia gate did I say Russia gate look
at Ukraine gate two impeachments wow one
side is objectively wrong all the time
what do I get criticism for bad
predictions bad predictions are
different from factual errors if I if I
see the stock market doing really really
well and then say I think Donald Trump's
gonna nail this election and that covet
happens and he doesn't that's just me
not realizing a pandemic was gonna
happen but when you say Donald Trump
colluded with Russia and he literally
did not or you claim these kids were
getting in the face of a Native American
and they literally did not you live in a
Twisted malformed decayed reality and
then if you become hateful and vile and
angry and or violent because of it yeah
one side is dangerous and when you have
a horde of angry Zombies how do you deal
with it that's a good question is there
anything to going deep in the woods yeah
that's literally what I did I left New
York City went to the middle of the
woods of New Hampshire joined the free
state project uh but but is there
anything that could help and again I
made this argument I don't think we
should call them zombies
um because there are people who could go
back from that state from that state of
watching the corporate media to waking
up zombies you can't bring back to life
uh when it comes to corporate media
heads who who watch the the fear-based
mind control people could come back from
that
um if people could come to an
understanding and say hey I could see
that so I don't think we should call
them zombies because I think that kind
of furthers the Divide but but let's
just call them zombies for now is there
anything bringing them back to life and
is there anything that could Heal The
Divide do you guys
but but I think when I would say zombie
I'm referring to the people who are
totally zombified I think there's some
people that you just can't bring back no
matter how you try to reason with them
no matter what type of facts you put in
front of them as was demonstrated I mean
you can agree with something everything
that you're they're saying basically and
they're still going to call you white
supremacists racists based off of these
new made-up definitions and terms and
they could be they could literally be a
white person sitting here yelling at you
that they could I've had white people
call me I'm anti-black and that I'm
racist and that I hate myself and I have
internalized racism and misogyny and all
those types of stuff and I can sit here
and look at them and laugh at them and
be like and just ask them to explain
themselves and they can't it's just
because like Tim said it's just I like
the word deviant it's just because I'm
deviant but there is a political
transformation there is a political
change and it happens in in some people
even even Tucker Carlson Tucker Carl but
it goes both ways pro-establishment of
course uh pro-establishment pro war CNN
MSNBC toting the line giving you know
repeating the speeches now he criticizes
the Republicans criticizes the Democrats
criticizes the intelligence age agencies
and does something degrees with Glenn
Greenwald yeah
I've been Greenwald on his show and
rages against the the kind of
intelligence State it's a new political
faction so so like some people would
consider him a zombie that has a zombie
Lord to someone who is come back to life
and is now helping people awaken from
this zombiness there's an article that
Daily Dot wrote about what happened here
and it was just like it's crazy how they
just don't watch the show they don't
care to get the facts straight but one
of the things they point out was in the
clip I highlighted a documentary I did
on Ferguson and the you know the black
community was going through with going
on tour and racism and they said but Tim
Poole failed to mention that he made
that before his politics did a 180. what
so let's assess that real quick if I
literally pull up a documentary I made
seven years ago and say I completely
agree with this message for the
documentary that I put together seven
years ago how have my politics changed
if I'm literally like this exemplifies
my view on on systemic racism quite
literally it's the same political
opinion as when the documentary was made
and I'll tell you this too they wanted
me to say a line in that documentary I
did not say they wanted me the final
line of the documentary was that the
police of St Louis are the are were
created by in the descendants of slave
slave catcher patrols and I was like
that's a little too much guys and it's
it's not necessarily untrue in some
contexts but it's it for the mo it's
mostly not true there are some police
departments where they started as you
know slave catching and then most police
departments and I looked all this up we
they were just ideas and institutions
that were were adopted from I think
France and other European countries that
we decided to implement here as we
expanded sheriff's department and law
enforcement so I'm like that goes too
far that's what they wanted in it so my
politics haven't changed on this but
it's really interesting because what
that means is this group of people
Revolt like they they they moved around
me
so here I am in this position on the
left and the establishment media moves
to the left where I stay in the same
position and now they're like look he
spawned a 180 and I'm like yo it's you
guys who wrapped all the way around the
other direction how is it that I'm gonna
defend this and you're gonna claim I
disagree with it they move so far left
that you look far right
and I haven't gone I haven't moved
anywhere I'm always just like hey it's
wrong to be racist yeah like I I what I
don't know I have to I gotta say this is
why I'm really pessimistic and at the
end of the member segment I said I think
racism will never go away right and it
was because of people like R.A it was
because he is a white guy who claims
white people are privileged who thinks
he's Justified as a white man to tell
minorities what to do and laugh at them
when when people when people talk about
their problems or experiences of racism
he laughs in their face and I was like
why would that go away it meh so this is
this is a guy who in every respect you
know 100 years ago probably would have
been a white supremacist 100 years ago
this country was overwhelmingly white
supremacist and now today many many
people have adopted the more civil
rights View and have become more
accepting and more understanding and
he's still of the mindset and it's not
just him I don't mean a single amount
it's it's the woke that they as the
white savior the privileged race has the
right to determine what minorities
should be doing and I'm like what
changed what about white supremacy has
changed and these people are still doing
it yeah I think that's why it's
important to be considerate of your
virtues and and not just change on every
issue based on your gang affiliation or
the level of political power you're
going to gain for standing on this side
or acceptance from larger society I mean
I always throughout my journalism career
always said okay what are my virtues
what what do I represent what ideas am I
going to go out there to the general
public and to me it was always anti-war
Freedom privacy the rights of
individuals over the collective and I
always stood on those virtues but I've
been called a right-wing racist tea
bagger by Chris Matthews of MSNBC Sean
I'm not sorry sorry not Sean Hannity
Bill O'Reilly said we are change is a is
a Jihad loving leftist liberal
organization and and I got slandered for
it but my position has never changed
when Obama was in power I was called a
conservative when Bush was in power I
was called a liberal and and again I
don't believe in any of that gang
affiliation your virtue should matter
more Luke has one political position
Freedom the government sucks yes
absolutely I'm with you I'm with you I'm
all for that with you abolish taxes all
of them immediately I'm in New York
where we have new mandates now for the
mask and it's just like if you if you
have kids and you love your kids you you
hate your government if they try to get
between you and your kids exactly and
they they're trying to wear I mean they
had like five-year-olds running around
outside the summer 90 degree weather
with the mask on
I'm like you guys are waterboarding
these kids basically what is the option
for New Yorkers like what do you leave
leave most of them can't fight I think
most of them let's in the city area like
it let's pull up the story real quick
too get some context here we have this
from timcast.com de Blasio says people
will be forced to accept coveted
vaccines if they're quote paychecks
depend on it wow this dude was giving an
interview and he basically said I will
destroy your life to get you to do what
we want you to do and I was just like if
you want to live in that City and you
want to live under his Boot and lick it
they like it feel free to do it if you
want to leave if you want to call
anything white supremacy that's it right
there if you look at the the vax
mandates who it predominantly affects
the the the consequences of it
especially in New York City especially
with people of color holy freaking his
name Wilhelm
I am absolutely you know my my favorite
reaction from that he still has any
political power my favorite one of my
favorite images of this year videos
really is him alone in Times Square
dancing with his wife when everyone was
not allowed to be in there everyone was
told get away you're not allowed to come
to Times Square only the special Elites
only the people who give out the orders
will be celebrating and dancing in the
middle of it as the order followers will
kick everyone out it was disgusting look
at this and the New York Times made that
one of the photos of the year that they
were celebrating and toting us something
great yeah they didn't show uh Bill de
Blasio dancing there by himself with his
wife with police officers protecting
them meanwhile the the governor's mass
murderer yeah they kicked out everyone
from Times Square and then they had
their private dance that's cute it's
cute
I think I think I I like your point that
people with kids people with families
should leave there's really nothing that
they could do I will not fault anybody
for leaving if there's really nothing
else that can do but I did write a piece
for Tim Cass it was in August I think it
was called here's how New Yorkers can
fight back against medical mandates
where I interviewed somebody from the
New York young Republican Club and they
talked about
um basically how they're like staging
like sit-ins and anti-mass protests and
rallies and I think non-compliance is
like a truly American virtue I mean it's
what basically birthed this country and
birthed this nation and I would be I
would hate to just have everyone Retreat
when I think I think there is a silent
majority I think it's time for them to
speak up and I know everyone's so tired
of them of everyone saying oh silent
majority of sound majority but I think
it's a real thing and I think people are
scared and if you and if you you can
afford to not leave and if you can
afford to you know not comply I think
you should I totally agree were they in
the city yep yeah so like that's a
different like the city is a whole
different world from the rest of New
York I said this last time like this New
York City is a little p at the bottom of
the state that kind of dictates the
policy for the rest of this giant State
and they vote sometimes overwhelmingly
read while the city votes blue I would I
would hope for non-compliance if you can
that's the way to go for sure
non-violent Civil Disobedience yes it's
as simple as people just being like no
just say no and then we will not comply
it's like a perfect American phrase and
it's just like we forgot about it or we
attributed to like white supremacists or
something Ben Shapiro did not forget
daily wire guys do not forget yeah
that's like they're they're all their
you know logo icons avatars or whatever
do not comply we will not comply it's
crazy how but they also retreated you
know like they left a state that was
pretty dystopian like New York but it's
good to say not not comply but I also
think sometimes
it's kind of you and it sends a message
to the state I I think it's kind of good
in some sense because it does send a
message and I think that people are
going to look at that and be like hey we
need to make a change or you know hey
some things yeah some people argue that
you're voting with your feet right by
staying in New York City you're paying
their taxes you're part of their
Workforce you're incentivizing people to
say I will control every aspect of your
life and you will obey and you will live
underneath my boot no I won't I'm going
to go to Florida I'm gonna go to New
Hampshire I'm gonna go to West Virginia
I'm going to go to Texas I'm going to go
where my rights are respected where my
money actually goes towards the greater
good and doesn't go towards
discriminating against people doesn't go
towards giving people less opportunities
because they didn't do a procedure that
a government bureaucrat wanted them to
do and it's it's sickening what's
happening in New York City and there are
some people standing up there was
recently a large number of people
arrested because they went to
restaurants and they said hey um we're
not going to comply with the whims of
government we're not going to ask the
government permission and get their
permission slip to eat here year and
they were asked to leave they said no
and they and they did sit-ins yeah cops
came in they followed orders and they
arrested them how isn't this weird it's
just it's just it's just so weird that
the the the way politics is evolving in
this country I've always been on the
side of businesses should apply public
should should Grant access to public
accommodation for members of the public
but now it's crazy to see many people on
the right arguing that you know what I
mean like before it's just I don't know
man I saw I saw a really crazy image of
a a building a vaccine Warehouse being
burned down and someone on the right
being like this is how you stick it to
authoritarianism whatever and I'm like
bro that's an anti-fatoon
but there I think that the difference
there is their angers rooted in
something that's really happening and
sometimes
are riding they're riding over
manipulated realities you know like
exact related numbers of you know deaths
whatever
um you know like I had a friend who
would tell me like thousands of black
men die you know a year right by cops
and I'm like I don't know if that's a
number it's like 23. I would show her
the number she would say well the
numbers are systemically racist and I
was like and then I'm racist for showing
her the sustainable racism oh my God oh
my goodness I had a friend and uh they
were posting stuff about the migrant
crisis
that was wrong so I took an I took the
the refugee document from the UN website
sent her the link and said hey just FYI
what's going on here is X Y and Z the
people coming from the the so there's
three Mediterranean Roots there's the
the Western the Central and the Eastern
I think it's I don't think it's called
Central but there was three routes one
goes through Spain one goes through from
Libya through Italy and then one goes
through Greece through lesvos and I was
just like the people who are coming in
through Greece are the refugees from
Afghanistan and Iraq and the people who
are coming from the Central and Western
routes are economic migrants from
Nigeria and other countries and then she
just said screw you and blocked me oh
and I was like I don't know what just
happened she slapped your microphone
yeah I did insult her and call her name
I had one friend this was crazy someone
I talked to all the time we hung out a
lot in New York
who told me that they now believed in
conversion therapy
because they so this is crazy right
check this out if you talk to someone on
the left they will cheer when you hear
someone say you know so like Canada has
banned conversion therapy they'll go
like yay
and I'm talking to this friend she's a
woman and she was saying that it was
transphobic for people to not want to
date people of the same sex if they were
transgender and so I was like all right
hold on let me let me like I'm trying to
understand you so I was like you're a
woman and you're attracted to men and
she was like yes and I said so so you're
saying that you personally
are attracted to bio like people who are
biologically female who have female
genitalia but have transitioned and she
said no and I said so do you think
that's transphobic and she said well I
could learn to like it and I said isn't
that conversion therapy like it's like
grooming like changing so like trying to
convert someone's sexuality and then she
got really mad and said no you're being
transphobic and I was like I thought you
were being transphobic I was like all I
did was genuinely ask she blocked me
yeah she but but to be fair she deleted
all of her social media and said I can't
take this anymore and I I think what
really happened is like when we talk
with with R.A these are people who are
on Facebook these are people on Twitter
and they get a world view bubble a
Bubble World from the group they follow
this is what people need to understand
who you follow on Twitter if you're
active on Twitter is shaping your
reality and it can be distorting it so
they say like like so I follow a lot of
conservative personalities a lot of
leftist and liberal personalities I
follow Hassan I follow vosh I follow
I follow a few other people I don't want
to get anyone else dragged they're
famous I'll leave it there but a few
other like lesser well-known leftist
journalists as well as all the
mainstream Publications Vice and uh that
way I'm seeing what they're saying I'm
seeing what people saying and I get a
view of both you know groups but a lot
of these people like this this you know
former friend of mine was probably only
on Facebook in a group of friends who
were all regurgitating the same woke
garbage and then when I simply asked
questions I think what what really
happened was she realized the world she
lived in on Facebook was not real and
she couldn't take the pressure of it
anymore and deleted it
scary I would even go further it's not
who you follow it's who the big Tech
algorithms decide you see because now it
doesn't even matter because they curate
a lot of the timelines Twitter is still
one of the few places where you actually
see the people you actually follow but
most social media especially Facebook
and Instagram they have a carefully
curated algorithm that they have even
done psychological studies on that could
create certain emotional outcomes and
there I I think there's a correlation
between the the mental and uh Wellness
of just people going down dramatically
with the onset of social media but it's
not just our personal well-being that's
being affected here it's not just our
mental health it's also our political
discourse which is being bastardized and
I think the echo chambers that are
created the echo chambers that many
people blindly follow because also as
you mentioned Tim you try to get
different perspectives but a lot of
people don't a lot of people don't want
to see different perspectives they want
to see their perspective regurgitated uh
to them from different kind of points
might not have time re-establishing the
same idea reinforcing that idea I got to
pull something up that's really funny
but you know keep keep talking I think I
think this is my crazy wacky theory is
Facebook years ago remember that debate
over if it's a blue dress or a gold
dress yeah that was us getting prepped
for the fracturing of reality oh who
believes what and they're just back
there they're judging who does what you
do a report I can't do it with Facebook
Instagram now I think I'm shadow of it
on Instagram even when people do see my
posts half the time it has that warning
over it like fact Checkers of deemed
this false and it'll be like the most
mundane thing badge of honor it's not
even like crazy I saw something on
Twitter earlier with someone talking
smack on vaccine mandates and right
below it was a promoted Pfizer tweet let
me let me let me pull up this story for
you guys Tim Poole confirmed leftist
this is from ground.news blind Spotter
and it says 53 of the news timcast
interacts with on Twitter leans left top
three influencers are vosh Michael malis
and Jack pesobic wow perfectly balanced
as all things should be now to be fair
the reason why it says most of the news
I interact with leans left is because
it's the New York Times it's CNN it's
Newsweek these are mainstream news
Publications
they lean left the media has a leftist
biased or a liberal bias Michael malice
is slightly leaning left with a big you
know right wing right right there vosh
is overwhelmingly left and Jack is
overwhelmingly right this right here is
really fascinating first of all I'm
obviously not a leftist but I think it's
fair to say that on policy issues and
certain certain issues I am Center left
you know libertarian a little uh you
know difference and opinion from Luke in
some ways but when you look at vosh his
worldview is comprised almost
exclusively of leftist media Michael
malice's worldview is mixed between
liberal and conservative media and Jack
pesobic is a little bit of liberal media
but mostly conservative media this makes
total sense based on the way the way
they interact with me the things they
believe the things they say why does
vosh think that you know the first time
he came here he said Tim Paul he told me
to my face you're far right because the
only media he interacts with is left
media who make up you know garbled
nonsense about me
now he says conservative why because he
actually came here and interacted with
me and now like he comes here and we
agreed on a bunch of stuff in fact when
we had the Charlie Kirk and wash debate
I was actually meant a lot of the stuff
he said I was like I agree with you
you're correct that point is true and
these things are true and then a lot of
people follow them were like oh I didn't
realize you know they're like based Tim
and things like that if these people
just mixed up their news sources a
little bit got a healthier balance
everyone might actually calm down the
problem is New York Times CNN Newsweek
my top three sources they lean left so
if vosh is just watching MSNBC CNN
reading the nation and all that stuff
and it's overwhelmingly left media then
I don't know how you break someone out
of that that broken reality can you put
anyone's Twitter yeah you want me do you
yeah yeah uh Luke we are change look we
are change it's gonna be like he's a
crackpot conspiracy guy look at that 44
left 44 left bro it's because the New
York Times zero head zero but it's
because because the New York Times is a
left-wing publication so when you when
you like ground news is a good job of
this look at that Thomas Massey Glenn
Greenland and cernovich are your sources
and their grand Glenn Greenwald is very
left when it comes to the media yeah and
then you've got cernovich who's very
balanced interestingly look how small
the center Centrist is in cernovich
Massey's got a little bit bigger one
Luke you've got a 21 moderate let's see
uh let's go back to mine because what
was the percentage of moderate for me 23
Center but most of it leans left why the
mainstream press is a liberal media
machine and this proves it let's let's
let's let's jump over to vosh look at
this he only interacts with 64 left wing
the New York Times The Daily Beast and
AJC what percent I can't I can't even
see the percent of right shoe one had
Ken klippenstein and Hassan the sun all
overwhelmingly left personalities so
vosh's world view is inherently broken
because he's not consuming media from
other people he's in an echo chamber
where he hears what he wants to hear and
I knew I mean mean no disrespect I you
know I respect that he was he was
actually being fair to a certain degree
when he was talking about the ra thing
he like he said if it was any other
mixed race person complaining about
racism you would be on their side but
because Tim Paul you don't like him he
is correct about that you know what I
think
vosh I think is a smart guy
I think if he actually started adding in
some non-left Wing news even like some
well he needs to mix in a little bit of
conservative sources he'd be like well
hold on how wait this right-wing Source
says X but the New York Times is why
where is the where's the break here and
I'll give you a really good example the
Washington examiner reports that the
January 6 committee admits to doctoring
the message from Jim Jordan to Mark
Meadows that is a fact what did the
independent report Jim Jordan confirms
he sent message to Mark Meadows the
objective truth is the message was from
Jim Jordan and it was altered
now if you only read the left Source you
probably don't know it was it was
altered really good example when we had
Hunter Avalon on the show and he said
Joe Biden didn't do anything wrong with
the quid pro quo and he didn't know
anything about Victor shoken and
zlachevsky and and and anything that
happened with barisma and I did
because not only did I read the
conservative Outlets the mainstream
Outlets I literally read Ukrainian news
sources on what was going on so if you
have people like vosh who only consume
Echo chamber content that's what you get
she won head look at this even Shuan had
a 76 she's worse than vosh but she does
have 13 you know uh conservative in
there and she just interacts for the
most part with people who are on the
left this is really interesting let's
take a look at a a conservative
personality Jack pesobic he's
overwhelmingly right wing and he
consumes media from people who are also
overwhelmingly in the right-wing sphere
I think it's fair to say you look at how
people consume news and you can predict
their viewpoints and how they view the
world I think everybody even Jack should
be reading a lot more of mainstream news
sources
well I I say Jack should read more
mainstream news sources because he's
clearly getting more right-wing sources
and you know Voss should read more
right-wing and independent sources
because he's clearly getting nothing but
mainstream sources you should treat it
like crossing the street you don't only
look right when you're crossing the
street especially in New York City with
the crazy drivers that they have in
there you look left and you look right
before crossing the street and I think
you know that's a perspective that's
gone for a lot of people a lot of the
people don't want to face a different
reality than the one that they're
codified in that the one that they feel
safe in and a lot of people do feel safe
by having their kind of political voices
reinforced their beliefs reinforced and
I'm a big fan of just waking them up
shocking them as much as you can and
having them wake up to the true reality
of the world this is why I think bench
right here we have Ben Shapiro this is
why I think Ben Shapiro is so smart so
quick and why he's like his opinions are
crafted by facts and he doesn't get
everything right I don't agree with all
of his opinions but you can see here
from his ground news blind spotter 38
percent of his news is left wing 18
percent is is moderate and 44 is right
wing it makes sense Ben's a conservative
guy he follows people who are are you
know consumed middle of the road across
the board look at this Steve Miller
redsties a healthy news diet in the
middle these are the people that I think
you know you are doing a good job when
Ben has a debate with someone like
Malcolm Nance and he Nails all of his
facts and his opinions are are crafted
by those facts well read well read right
from from good sourcing and mixing it up
and trying to understand both sides I
grew up with like 10 channels and my
dad's like a Centrist leans right but he
would always tell us like you gotta
watch everything like and I would always
notice when he got into like friendly
debates at Thanksgiving or something he
would know the other person's argument
if they happen to be on the other side
rather than they knew his argument so
he's arguing their point and his point
and they're hearing things from him that
are completely like from another world
to them so it's even being able to to be
willing to to have those conversations a
lot of people are afraid of having those
conversations they're prevented at
having those conversations so even
though yesterday was kind of a a crap
show the conversation at least I think
people were kind of forced to have it
and I think there's a layer of it too
that we could still Salvage from the
craziness some kind of understanding
from where other people are coming from
and I think one of the biggest signs of
intelligence is being able to have an
open mind if you're able to hear ideas
that are critical of yours without
having an emotional reaction and you
could logically critically think about
them and assess the facts of the case
very few people do that they just want
to be emotionally click baited into
something that makes them feel nice look
and and reinforces their side let me
tell you why Brian stelter will never
never be on par with Ben Shapiro and
this is a good example 90 of what he
interacts with as a media correspondent
for CNN is left-wing media Oliver Darcy
who is a media correspondent for CNN a
85 percent left-wing content these are
the guys who are supposed to be covering
the right they don't even read it
reliable sources the media show on CNN
is 99
left-wing media they do not interact
with anyone but themselves these guys
are sitting at the bottom of a well
talking to each other about actually you
know what they're they're the people
sitting in the cave the allegory of the
cave looking at the Shadows to thinking
they know the world and they're not
interacting with it at all so this is
something that I mentioned to Olivia
when I was driving her over because I
was like I don't want to argue with
someone who doesn't understand what
we're talking about I want someone who's
well read well informed someone who can
change my perspective because they know
facts that I don't like talking about
redlining and blockbusting that's stuff
I want to know about because that
changes my view on stuff like systemic
racism but it's very hard to find
someone on the left maybe it's just
because it's easier to only read
left-wing sources like what Brian
stelter apparently is doing I cannot
believe that these are the people that
they choose to cover the media I forget
who it was who's advertising for a
right-wing media like reporter I was
like well as far as I know as far as
these people are telling me the right
wing doesn't even exist there is none
yeah I I think there's also a debate to
be had with a lot of people on the left
wanting to give handouts wanting to help
others so they don't have to work
towards something because when you have
an idea that contradicts your Viewpoint
you have to work to combat it and I
think there's an aspect of people having
the ability to be able to work and I
think maybe that's why a lot of
right-wingers are for work for having
this kind kind of protestant work ethic
compared to people who want to be the
mother in our kind or larger society and
give people help and be their supportive
role and I think a healthy Society has a
mod a mother figure and a father figure
that has
both kind of influence on people's lives
so they get a fair perspective on it
because if you go too far in either
direction you're going to be in an
unhealthy Direction you're going to be
unbalanced and you're not going to be a
person that's going to kind of fare well
with the kind of rules and circumstances
of our society so I want to pull up this
is called Mediapolis from ground news
you can see 32 percent of the news Tim
pool interacts with on Twitter is Media
conglomerate owned Tim pool is a
slightly concentrated news diet so you
can see 11 percent of the news I consume
is independent or it does say I think it
interacts with mostly mainstream media
then private Equity then wealthy private
owners telecom companies and other
I want to do this I'm going to pull up
look at all this let me go back I'm
going to pull up Luke we are change
and I'm willing to bet Luke has a here's
my bat Luke's gonna have a big
Independent Media bubble what do you
think Luke probably you think so yeah
not so much because actually smaller
than mine by one percent you have
wealthy private owners followed by media
conglomerates and private Equity but
here's the reason here's why here's why
I pulled this up what do you think is
going to happen when I pull up Brian
stelter yeah
let's find out Brian stelter media
reporter for CNN oh he he's
overwhelmingly telecom companies now
that's probably because CNN
because he he he's within the CNN bubble
reliable sources 96 Telecom
Oliver Darcy Telecom
these these people live not only in a in
in a bubble of leftism but they only
really interact probably with with the
news coming out of their own network
which is full of garbage and as we can
see heavily biased so they're they're
effectively the way I described it with
Jack Dorsey is that his worldview was
shaped by gargling the sewage of of his
own platform he created a platform it
had a it had a negative effect on
society producing extreme activism he
then consumed it all and came to believe
the garbage coming out of his own
machine stop it man you're getting
you're giving me
him literally doing that I think Jack
Dorsey has been Unleashed I think he was
constrained a bit by Twitter being the
CEO now that he's out the one thing he
tweeted was transitorian quotes he
tweeted that rothbard recently yeah I'm
willing to bet now that he's not there
he's going to give it some time he might
come out and actually start blowing
people's minds no joke that'd be nice
would be great I hit him up actually he
uh it would be great to interview I said
if you want to come on the show and talk
about his views on blockchain you know
and and the future of social media and
he said
um at some point that'd be great well
he's huge more than I can say for a lot
of other people he's huge into
decentralized currencies and him you
know tweeting out rothbart it just is
just a perfect example of people
realizing the true power of
decentralization and understanding that
if you try to control everything in life
and centralize power you're creating
real life harm that translates to of
course the natural stopping of human
progression but Luke we got to get for
we got to get real we gotta get serious
there is serious harm that may be coming
for all of us and it's this story right
here group of monkeys kill over 250 dogs
for revenge in Indian Town what if they
come for us what I'm just kidding
right about Friday night Friday night
and we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
leave on on a it's not actually a good
note this is actually yeah this is
volume two of our book I read this story
and I felt depressed like seriously it's
sad what's happening is there a video
there's video oh my God
group of monkeys I need to know what
happened no there's a video of them
rescuing a puppy from the monkey so look
at this a group of monkeys in a small
town in India took revenge on the local
dog population by throwing them off the
top of buildings and trees it's reported
the monkeys have killed about 250 pups
in the process and are targeting
villagers the monkeys located in malagon
India started the Rampage after some of
the dogs allegedly killed an infant
monkey news 18 reported that when the
monkey sees a dog approach they catch
them and throw them from a significant
height to the ground in the neighboring
Village of lavul the monkeys have
eradicated all of the dogs after all the
dogs were killed in the village
residents contacted Forest Department
officials to catch the monkeys but when
officials attempted to catch the monkeys
they were unable to capture a single
monkey villagers believe the monkeys are
taking revenge on the dogs now villagers
in lavul are being chased by the monkeys
some have even been attacked quote we've
seen that when an individual is attacked
in some way the likelihood of them
attacking someone related to their
aggressor is higher typically there's a
preference for attacking a third party
associated with the original aggressor
as opposed to the actual aggressor for
the most part these acts of Revenge take
place shortly after the attack
all right we got real serious throughout
the previous segments this one's
actually kind of a messed up story but
at least we can wind down on a Friday
night and get our minds out of that dark
place and talk about monkeys the dogs
are reading too much Brian stelter the
monkeys are yeah maybe the monkeys were
the monkeys are the monkeys I was going
to make a communist reference but I
should I'm going to stop myself there
the monkeys have been on Facebook
reading about how dogs are evil and they
just wanted all the dogs to drop dead
and they went out there and started
throwing dogs off roofs I spent some
time in India the the monkeys there
called the shots I mean seriously if
you're I I mean around the Taj Mahal
area in Mumbai in Mumbai they're like
the ones
um that's also in in Thailand there's
there's literally people making money
off people going on beaches monkeys Rob
them and then you pay the locals a few
dollars and they'll get your stuff back
but uh in India especially outside of
the Taj Mahal there's monkeys running
around all over the place and and there
like if they were want something from
you they're going to get it we need
Cassandra's view on this story yeah
she's become a rather a bit of a monkey
expert oh yeah do you guys see that that
crazy video where during the lockdown
the the baboons had no food so there
were roving gangs of baboons attacking
each other for food like they they it
was like they went Bloods and Crips you
know like we're in the dystopia yeah
that's right you know like Rise of the
Planet
of the spirit yeah I think I'd like to
title our reality the Omega variant you
know like because that's the last
variant you know that's where we're
headed and it sounds cool the Omega
variant and because you know we're in a
Sci-Fi dystopia with all of this stuff
going on yeah and I I would just like to
call it that yeah the only place that's
safe is the metaverse
oh yeah well there's also monkey uh
castles in India where monkeys get
worshiped and there's monkey tribes
fighting other monkey tribes for the top
position of their group to be inside of
this monkey casual monkey castle where
they get worshiped by the locals and fed
by the locals so uh there's also stories
of monkeys attacking people because of a
lack of tourists in other South Asian
countries and just hordes of monkeys uh
just pretty much running entire cities
in South Asia new thing peace from
Newsweek can monkeys be racist let's
find out well it depends what's the race
of the dog so the dogs chocolate labs
are white adjacent are they yeah they're
white passing yeah yeah white passing
dogs well this dog is actually white on
its front and brown on its back so I
don't know mixed it's it's white passing
right yeah there's any amount of white
in there no good no good the monkeys are
gonna come for us that's true did you
did you there was a show I was watching
it was called like after humans or
something I forgot what it's called and
they said that if you if humans
disappeared right now if every single
person on the planet was just gone house
cats would take over
yeah because they're the only they
reproduce like crazy and they're the
only species besides humans that kill
for fun oh yeah yeah they hunt for fun
they kill for fun and so they just
needlessly destroy and expand and kill
and man
cats dude not a fan of cats oh yeah
they literally torture animals for fun
my cat brings me a decapitated Mouse
yeah quite often yeah yeah okay it's
treasure we had a focus our cat he was
uh we went outside and he had he was
holding a bird a little bluebird and
then he would it was its wing was busted
so he would let it go and it would
struggle and jump off and then he would
pounce that and whack it and whack it
and whack it we had to put the bird down
it was this little tiny little tiny bird
because like it it had been eviscerated
and so we were like what do we do like
we just gotta you know and then there
was another time where I saw him sitting
in the grass looking around and I went
out there and there was a little mouse
on its back just like wheezing and then
it rolled over and started to crawl away
and then he just got ready and then he
let it go a little bit then he jumped up
and started bashing it over and over
again so I took a little stick and I put
it under the hand of The Mouse and the
mouse grabbed onto it and I lifted it up
and he was just hanging there dangling
and and Boca started going like yelling
at me I put the mouse in a bush I think
he survived because Buck was just
beating him but he didn't he didn't gut
him or anything like that cats are
brutal yeah
Mouse rescuer you want to know what's
the most brutal thing I saw okay it's
one thing when bocus is like stalking
the mouse and and and swatting it a
mouse was walking past the chicken coop
and a chicken ran over and grabbed it
bashed the mouse with its beak against
against the ground and then just
swallowed it whole and I was like oh my
God that's like some ancient DNA
pterodactyl stuff little dinosaurs man
dude it swallows
yeah no that I I I didn't see that
happen I was told by uh some of the
people here that like they saw it grab
the mouse and just bash it and then and
I was like whoa that's your protein in
the eggs yeah yeah dude they eat they
eat chickens nature is you know that
chickens are gonna eat each other yeah
so we had we had uh yeah Dorothy one of
our chickens was was getting injured
I gotta be honest Dorothy's kind of a
[ __ ]
she's not here to defend herself she was
attacking she was bullying the other
chickens and so the other chickens
teamed up and Roberto the rooster
started he would jump on her and he
wasn't he wasn't he wasn't doing the
business because you know like he would
just jump on her pecking her head like
crazy and then she would scream and run
away and her back was all messed up
and so I we I looked it up we had people
comment on the show they said if she
starts bleeding the other chickens will
peck her to death and then eat the body
so we we separated them for about two or
three weeks Dorothy fully healed we
reintroduced her they're all getting
along just fine now it's fantastic we're
getting the cameras out of our channel
so there's hope you're saying for people
yeah
well so a couple weeks is the equivalent
to a chicken of maybe like a year yeah
wow none of these chickens are Dorothy's
a uh a year and a half old wow the other
adult chickens are were born in January
so they're almost a year so they were
separated for about three weeks
right so that's like you know maybe like
a year or two years of their lives and
reintroduce them and they'll be like
[ __ ] I haven't seen you in so long I
can't remember why we were mad at each
other you know I want to eat you
okay are you injured hey guys he is
injured though that's food we should eat
it as humans right now we are so lucky
and so protected from the realities of
nature uh because again like if if ish
starts to get real if there's going to
be a lack of resources a lack of food
it's going to be a very natural process
of what's going to be taking place and a
lot of us are not used to Nature a lot
of us are not used to the wild not a lot
of us don't even understand how the wild
works and I think you know with all the
crazy stuff happening I think people are
going to get a very rude awakening soon
I was raised by like a crazy prepper
like a doomsday prepper yeah we had like
we literally had like a Go trailer like
in the garage that we could like hook up
and just go we never had to use it but I
was just raised that way I think I would
survive an apocalypse vehicle yes we did
yeah are there some like other prepper
tips that you would share with people
that you learned I learned a lot of
weird stuff as a child like I mean I was
in Middle School like chopping down
bamboo that just kind of randomly grew I
live on the edge of like uh Seneca Creek
which is off of the Potomac and it's my
house kind of backs up to the woods and
there's like a kind of random shoot of
bamboo that shop I think for privacy for
my neighbor but there's a bunch of dead
uh bamboo down there in middle school I
would take it and wrap a fishing line
around it and catch salamanders and
catch catfish in the Seneca Creek and I
was like that was like my little like
teenage girl thing I had no friends and
I was like oh my God what is that why
does everyone think I'm weird but like
just like little stuff like that that
was normal to me growing up I learned
how to
um like uh treat and Clean cambian from
pine trees to eat and make tea with I
learned how to make like flour from
acorns a lot of weird stuff like that
are you having to make a ham acorns you
ever make dandelion tea yeah Ian talks
about that a lot he was like yo we got
to make dinner
is it good yeah I love it pine tea from
made from cambians also pretty good I've
made Acorn tea as well like it's kind of
more of like a Nutty coffee flavor if
you do it with acorns but yeah we got
probably 300 pounds of black walnut
outside you ever you ever do anything
with that it's apparently like an
anti-parasitic or something but you're
not supposed to like eat a lot of it I
don't know
we have pawpaw like crazy in October
though I remember the day I met you you
made mulberry jam yeah yeah you may give
me a cookie with some mulberry jam we
made the best thing we made with my we
so we have wild wine berries everywhere
in West Virginia I saw a guy driving on
the highway pull over his car jump out
and start grabbing berries from the side
of the road I'm not kidding they're
delicious they're like a Chinese
raspberry we took those and we took
lemon juice now you use a little bit of
lemon juice you're making a jam but I
did a lot of lemon juice to make a lemon
wineberry jam it was amazing and then we
made we put it on cheesecake so good I
got news though I got good news we were
trying to get this building built we got
a building getting built we're gonna
have freedomastan timcast HQ an official
big steel construct Building 7 500
square feet with a new studio being
built out specifically inside of it we
got this confirmed today I didn't think
we'll be able to pull it off because of
the shortages and the price increases
but we finally found a company that said
we can get this done
it's smaller than we originally wanted
but it's going to be mostly Big Empty
open space for now and then there's
going to be a small area that's about 20
feet by 75 feet that will comprise the
studio it's going to be a second floor
construct and then we're going to have a
legit headquarters in West Virginia for
everything we're still going to have
this space for production and editorial
and everything but we're growing like
crazy it's incredible yeah we're growing
like mad crazy it's good news yeah and
it's thanks to everybody who's a member
who's a member at timcast.com supporting
all of all the work we do and uh it's a
hefty ticket like it's expensive to do
but it's like I've been saying we want
we want to do a lot we need space we
want to do the the the truth and media
Foundation we want to fact check the
fake media we need office space for this
we want to do the technology stuff we
need office space for this so we're
going to start building out the space we
need it's actually cheaper to build on
this land than it would be to go buy a
building and deal with it plus it's
going to be built made to order so it's
specifically for us and everything we
need
man it's crazy that we're getting this
stuff done so hopefully you know I'll
put it this way the fact that this is
all happening is the best evidence that
we are winning that Success is Not only
possible but it's happened before it's
happening now and is going to continue
happening so that's good news for for
that's a very optimistic thing I think
and I also want to add because someone
super chatted this that I am in fact a
Pokemon he is yes uh it's a Pokemon
called timpole
literally it's called Temple and it's
the Pokemon wearing headphones kind of
looks like you it does isn't it and it's
got the same colors yeah
isn't that really weird who came first I
love him uh Temple was made uh well
before I was using it's really crazy the
colors we use for timcast
the the name Tim Paul simulation and
yeah simulation for sure but I so like
we use the teal and the black as the
colors on the website he swims isn't
that weird yeah that's weird maybe the
true version of you in the alternate
reality a part of this larger kind of uh
Consciousness that we're a part of was
just kind of trolling
I don't know but somebody somebody super
chatted they're like why didn't you tell
us that you were a uh Pokemon and I was
like other people have sent us this
before Tim pole Temple that's weird so
weird yeah it's like a tadpole I guess
yeah yep so cute well that's that's even
the right water sign how funny yeah that
is and I'm a Pisces yeah exactly that's
what I'm saying yeah
so do we live in a simulation pick up
your copy of copy of the inverted World
Book Perfect Look at that inverted
worldbook.com uh one thing we can do
though is we can jump over to the super
chats yes if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and um Ian couldn't be with us tonight
so I need you to smash that like button
for him Ian wherever you may be or
smashing that like button for you no he
went home to see his family it's not a
big deal he'll be back we should have
said there was a fight and like yeah
yeah
but he said he we got a mysterious
message that said I'll only come back if
you get 10 000 likes and we were like
how do we oh geez no it was a letter and
it was like get 10 000 likes you'll
never see Ian again
Tim poll all right let's see we got here
all right let's see drive by commenter
says hey Tim a quick response you can
say on CRT is I agree with teaching all
history but I reject the deliberate
polarization and weaponization of the
youth in their formative years
yeah it's it's hard for people who don't
know what's going on to understand
that's why I like you know we're talking
with R.A I said I don't think critical
race Theory should be banned it goes but
you were cheering for it and I was like
we're cheering for the Banning of the
Praxis like it's I I imagine this should
be simple for most people would you want
a teacher to tell a child to you know oh
you you failed your test so I want you
to you know sit down and and do seven
Hail Mary's and three our fathers you'd
be like I don't think that should be in
a public school because it's a religious
practice I feel the exact same way about
that if if there was a bill being passed
that said or if I found out all these
teachers across the country were bring
out books that said sit down and and
close your eyes and reflect on how
you've you know sinned and how you need
to confess to the Lord and do all these
religious things I'd be like nah I'm not
okay with that right that's that's a
public school and there's there's issues
with that same thing you can't have it
they can't have whatever they want you
know
recommorsen says so when's the sequel
song will of the elites I have a new
song I'm extremely excited for I don't
you know what I think I can tell the
story of the song right now because
right normally like when we did Will of
the people I waited for it to come out
so people get the full song because the
the the the song is a a story but the
song I'm working on now I'll give you
the really quick version so it'll it'll
spoil it for a lot of not I'm not gonna
do it don't do it I don't want to spoil
it don't spoil it it's really good
though but I'll tell you the gist of it
it's uh it's not a dark and evil song
like you know it's it's just a song
about perseverance it's about a kid who
wants to defy the The Establishment
that's trying to mold him to be what
they wanted to be but he really wants to
just be like you know he wants to be a
scientist he wants to explore he wants
to find his own path in life so that's
basically it but it's a really good
story that that I wrote and I've got the
video planned out for it the song is is
already mostly formulated so and then
we're also actually done we're getting
really close to being done with one song
which is uh fairly dark called Bright
Eyes which you may have seen in the Vlog
you can check that out we got Pete
Parada Lang drum tracks for us I could
not be more excited about that as a huge
fan of The Offspring growing up and then
having Pete you know help us with the
drums is just absolutely incredible Pete
you rock thank you so much all right
let's see what we got here the
physicality Channel says I'm not that
guy which guy
which guy is he referring to I don't
know no idea
Daniel Cavin says Tim I am 25 Japanese
and it was always my leftist friends
that would say it doesn't count I am the
same age as you and when I fly I get
pulled also it was it's the weirdest
thing that like I don't know man that
you have people who say there's no
possible way you could experience racism
and then they claim they're not the
racists it's just weird anyway
Alan dejane says if one wants to ask
others to relate to their struggles they
must give Credence to other struggles
understanding works best as a two-way
Lane and uh uh shout out to vosh again
because he made a really great point he
said when someone tells you their
experience
you do not call them a liar or deny it
why would you ever because they are the
experts on them you always say okay and
or okay but and you carry on accepting
you know unless you he's like unless you
can means test and prove they're making
a story up if someone says is what they
went through then you accept it what
happened to speaking your truth right
well it's because that that's why I say
a lot of these people are just overtly
racist but I I will say too in that
capacity
I do think vosh is an overt
authoritarian masquerading as a
Libertarian and that is not meant to be
like a point of derision or or
disrespect it's just a an opinion based
statement of how I view him and it was
because he made a troll video where he
was saying it was bait that he said
Assan should rotten a CIA black site as
long as it offends Glenn green although
whatever and I just
I understand he may be joking or
screwing around or whatever but I'm just
like uh
I I genuine I don't actually trust that
he's joking in that capacity I don't
think he he's he's as um
being as literal as he wants Julian
Sanchez to die in Australia black site
but I genuinely do not believe he
supports Julian Assange and I gotta be
honest
overwhelmingly if you oppose our sanj
did it is typically because you're an
authoritarian and what Assange did was
journalism
that's just it so I I don't trust him
authoritarians currency absolutely
because it disrupts The Authority you
know
Daniel kaiso says my first Super Chat I
believe you guys are the future both
your show and your ideas shout out to
Knowles's book you know the thing and be
strong walruses
Nathaniel Curry says I'm not that guy
smash the like button y'all that's right
that's right if you are not that guy
smash that like button
I want to say something too look
afterwards you know there are people who
are like Tim why would you apologize to
that guy and I'm like because I don't
want to fight people because I'm trying
not to have conflict and because I I
recognize we disagree and we both got
mad and I said this earlier I take full
responsibility for everything happened
last night why I I believe that I should
not invite people into my house who are
going to disagree with me and then have
me get mad at them and yell at them for
it I'd get mad at them I can disagree
with them I can I can get mad but if I
ask someone to come here because I'm
going to talk politics with them and
they don't like my politics I should not
be I should not be raising my voice
about that you know I I do I do think
there's some criticism to go to ra for
calling me a [ __ ] and laughing at me
and raising his voice to me and then he
got mad when I did the same but I think
I have an obligation as the host who's
asked them to do me the favor of
traveling coming on my show for free
helping me do a show and then me getting
mad at them I should have done that I
shouldn't have done that so it's one of
my personal pet peeves when other people
try to tell you what you think this is
something that happens a lot on the
internet it happens to me in real life I
once mentioned that I had a hard time
dealing with people from a certain State
someone contradicted me and I was like
I'm telling you what's happened to me
what's going on why are you telling me
that I'm wrong with what I'm telling you
about what happened to me this is just
what I've experienced one of the things
that you can't say is true or false is
what has happened to someone else or
what their opinion is that is not
something that is falsifiable in any
manner you can't just contradict someone
and people don't even know what they
think themselves they're very bad at
communicating what they themselves are
feeling so to tell someone you know what
they're thinking or feeling get out of
here and I want to make something clear
too is the weirdest thing there's two
there's two important points I did say
this earlier but I say it again that uh
there's people on the left and the right
saying the left is saying Tim was a
coward and look how fast he backed down
when R.A you know stood up and put him
in his place and there's people on the
right saying damn Tim didn't even Flinch
he kept his cool and my response is
neither of those apply to the
circumstances because I don't think
anyone here thought R.A was actually
going to attack anybody no he just got
mad and he smacked the mic yeah so
there's nothing for me to be scared of I
didn't think like I feel like it's a
weird insult to R.A to imply that he was
he was going to lose his cool and attack
us I I do not believe that for a second
so I wasn't being brave I wasn't being
scared I literally was just like the
dude stood up and hit the mic didn't
come after anybody and I do want to
stress this point too that's really
weird
there's people on the left saying that I
didn't understand what he was saying
when he said I'm not that guy and I'm
like why do you think I apologized to
him I told him you are that guy I know
exactly what that meant it was an insult
I was directly insulting him saying that
he he what he was he was going to sit
back and take it and I I called him a
mother effer and I said bad words and I
was like bro I should not have snapped
like that so I fully recognize I was
being disrespectful to a guy and I
invited to come on my show to do me a
favor and that was wrong of me that
that's just right there so some people
are like Tim don't back down not a dude
I I I I have to say this play plainly if
the goal of this show is to ask people
to come on for free and then we run a
business we make money and we hire
people we expand you know these people
are all doing me a favor
so I can I can accept that if I invite
someone here they might not like me or
agree with me I should not raise my
voice at them
and you end it with a hug ended with a
hug and he wrote a nice thing on Twitter
that's right you do too that I knew and
he said like they're gonna take that
clip and then that's why the first thing
first thing I wake up and I see was
trending I'm like yeah here we go I was
like no one's posting that we hugged man
right we hug for like a good 20 seconds
and we were both like I'm sorry dude we
you know that should be the shirt and
people too there's a lot of disrespect
for him bro like as a skateboarder as as
you know he he's got that that song King
of the underground and Tony Hawk's
Underground we know Ari the rugged man
dude that song is awesome absolutely and
we wish I was there I wanna I wanna sit
face to face with a white man telling me
about the black experience and calling
me a racist and tell me why supremacists
yeah I just let's make that happen I
love when I get in these situations and
it doesn't happen often because usually
they'll they'll understand before they
talk to me like yeah she's probably not
the best person to you know why explain
about the black experience too but
occasionally it will happen usually on
Twitter
um when you're not face to face with
somebody but I would just love to sit
down with somebody who is so deluded
like I think we needed another Thrilla
in Manila too
with other people who are going to come
on I think I I think there deserves to
be a Redemption moment and a moment
where we could Converse about this and
give it another try where we could try
to understand each other with other
people involved that would be the best
outcome yeah for sure Ian shop says hey
Tim and crew ended up checking out
vosh's take on the viral clip and given
he didn't see the two prior hours he had
a good take overall but his comment
section was gross a non-trivial portion
just criticized your personal appearance
well that's because they're jealous oh
yeah of course over the past several
months I've been doing keto and I've
lost a good amount of weights right and
I've been skating you know what you know
it's really incredible you get your diet
right it's not even about losing weight
it was it was about me realizing that we
talk bad about sugar all day every day
and I was eating trash I was like during
the day I'd be like oh you know I'll get
something good like some rice and beef
or something and then at night I'd be
like what's one pack of gummy bears
what's one Stroop waffle it's no big
deal it's just one so it was good all
day yeah exactly
and and now I'm just like I'm not
touching any of that stuff that's great
the worst thing I had today was a hot
dog I actually ate the bun that's right
but it was like you know I'm I I have
substantially reduced just bad stuff in
my diet I still eat some bad stuff we
had pizzas I just took the cheese and I
ate the cheese because I'm like I I
can't walk and we had but we have keto
pizzas we have Quest keto pizzas I put
jardinera on it man that's keto cookies
too
the quest Pizza it was actually pretty
good we are not sponsored by questions
it's so good yeah it's awesome all right
let's see km says Michael Graves instead
of Danzig whack uh Michael Graves
couldn't make it unfortunately
eventually rescheduled yeah we were
really excited but you know these last
minute things they that that's why we're
like we never announced guests and I
said it I was like we don't normally do
this but Michael Graves is coming and
then he's like I can't make it dude
uh your mum says one of the Friday night
music jams come Jam's coming back
wait until we get this the the uh the
new space out of it for damastan is
going to be awesome oh yeah Friday night
what I wanted to do was actually have
semi members only uh Friday nights so
what we would do is
here's what I'm thinking for the next
year
by the by March we should have the
building
by maybe may we should have the studio
so we're talking about end of next
spring getting into next summer
what we can do is on Friday night shows
after the show ends we keep it going
live and we have about 20 website
members who can sign up for tickets or
put on a wait list for them and then you
get invited out to come hang out you
know or do a concert outside with
thousands of people coming in we'll do
that but we can't do that every Friday
you know so it would be like 20 to 30
people in this big space hanging out as
like a mixer with drinks and snacks and
some music and then we'll film the music
but maybe like once a month or every
hour once a month waiver
outdoor stage will get like a big band
like like legit you know we'll hire a
legit big band and we'll have tons of
people but that requires a ton of
comedians yeah definitely dude
definitely we're super stoked on working
with Ryan long because that dude is a
genius oh he's funny I just got to see
him when I was in California like a
month ago he was hilarious he's great
absolutely fantastic all right let's see
James gross says I saw the ra show from
yesterday this morning and he was
hammering the black experience as a
topic got me wondering if you consider
it consider asking Anthony Brian Logan
on the show I'm not familiar with him
he's awesome yeah yeah yeah what's his
what's his what's his bit what do you
say Shane he just covers the culture War
I think and uh sees it yeah he wears
great hats he does yeah he's really
smart
he's cool
Bob samarchik says as a Slavic person of
color I'm personally offended by the
White Privilege demonstrated by
tonight's panel
damn right I should have been leading
the show here it should be rootcast yeah
but but Luke are you what percentage
polish are you are you 100 you're 100
wow I'm about 40 polish though oh so
you're mixed right so yeah I am like
Irish too I'm here you're like yeah down
here
well I don't know actually that would
make Shane mixed race so yeah there's
less mixed race people then but I'm
totally Slavic
I just wanna
my family left Poland too
but I I just fought them no I left
Poland yeah that's right you left Poland
yeah that's right that's right I left
New York I mean that's Poland of today
one 2.0 yeah
yeah we're doing really good now that's
right this is a good one Nova Carrillo
says vash's take on the ra video quote
look Tim pool is a conservative and that
means by necessity you're going to be a
racist exactly
yeah I think vosh needs to just watch
the show he would benefit yes
yes because I think of black
conservatives if black people can't be
racist I don't think he believes that I
don't think he believes that oh okay
yeah like we we've actually had really
good conversations and I think for the
most part on the core of issues we agree
but on reality he lives in a left bubble
like I actually pulled up I I pulled up
proof of that with ground news showing
you know like what 80 85 percent of his
interaction is all left-wing media
so I don't I don't think he actually
knows the perspective of us or people on
the right so he can certainly understand
that like the things that the left are
doing that he disagrees with that are
fun are principally wrong but he doesn't
understand what our opinions are because
he doesn't he like when he came here he
was like you're far right and I was like
what like have you ever listened to what
I've had to say I was like I could
understand someone calling me a moderate
Centrist or even center right if they
want to make an argument but like far
right and even conservative not only has
he listened to you but he's never
listened to a far-right person then
right he's actually saying that yeah and
what does far right really mean I don't
know nothing anymore it doesn't mean
anything they're like laissez-faire
capitalists or are they Nazis right
liberal doesn't mean anything either
yeah classical liberal but people think
that's far right depending on where
you're standing on the Spectrum all
right I gotta address it really now says
not gonna lie last night was the first
time I disliked a Tim Caster that guest
was dumb well I'll put it this way
um you are free
to dislike all of our videos If you
believe the video and the substance of
the content we produce deserves to be
disliked but I will push back and say if
you dislike the content we produce like
you you click the button because you
disagree with the guest
well that hurts us right that that hurts
us in the long run so my attitude is
like
I think it was good that we had Ari on
the show and we had this discussion and
heated debate because I don't want to be
in an echo chamber I want to bring on
guests that that argue with us and
challenge us and I thought it was
actually a fantastic example of
everything I disagree with when it comes
to wokeness and so I thought that was
that was good I thought it was good and
some people even pointed out you got to
hear me Luke and and Lydia and Ian
express our ideas on issues more in
depth than we normally would because we
usually don't have someone there
presenting those arguments so I think
it's it's good and if you like the show
then you give us a like if you don't
like a particular show just because
whatever feel free to give us dislike
Eric Miller says maybe wokeness isn't a
cult but an infection and they're just
Mindless super spreaders I think ARA was
just trapped in a CRT bubble to the
point he just straw manned all night be
uh but respect for showing up yeah and
and you Lydia you sent him videos so he
knew exactly yeah but I think I think
the problem was that was his only
exposure to the show so like he didn't
see the seven or eight videos I made
saying that Chauvin was wrong he saw
only the court trial videos where I was
like whoa the prosecutors dropped
screwing this case up like crazy and it
looks like on the merits a manslaughter
case he didn't like that but he didn't
see anything else I said anything else I
reported on it's funny when people are
like when have you ever spoken up about
what happened with George Floyd and I'm
like here's five video links to my
videos and people are like oh whoa I
didn't know that I'm like just watch my
show dude don't get your news from memes
yeah I'm more than a meme
people get their news from memes man
yeah for sure you know
okay Daniel Irving says part of the
problem is that most people that scream
racist have never seen an actual racist
and I love it how yesterday I kept
calling R.A racist and the left was like
upset about it they were like how dare
he and I'm like I know it's kind of
weird because like technically correct
yeah he's a white dude right isn't he
inherently racist and he can do no he
can do no he like he has to he has to
accept his racism and bow down to CRT
and all that stuff
all right let's see if we got some other
uh
what is this Joshua Albritton says can I
please get a business shout out for Papa
albritton's Florida cowhips
hope you received and liked the whip I
made for you I'm trying to sell enough
to earn 4K for tuition for trucking
school oh my gosh is this the guy that
sent the whip because I freaking love
whips my dad used to have one and I
still know how to work one and I love it
it's awesome this is a family-friendly
show Linda please I just thought that
was like a racist dog whistle
I don't know about that one Lydia no it
was it was really well made it's really
well I'm tightly braided yeah okay all
right Olivia y'all down calm down okay
the show's taking a great turn
I'm just saying I had to bring it there
all right Luke calm down
okay
zorark graft says bro ARA is so far gone
that last year he made a statement
saying he was a better rapper than
Eminem the full amount of delusion is
understandable now
um well I don't know about being better
than Eminem but I will say
he's actually really good he's pretty
good did you see Eminem's like rap
against Trump I mean there's an argument
to make there
Eminem made an anti-woke rap that was
just not really that good Eminem's had
had good stuff in the back and in the
past but look just because you guys
don't like the the argument we got into
and you and and I'm critical of the guy
I legit think you got to watch this
stuff because he is really good at what
he does but I think even he said it that
one of the things that held him back
from bigger Fame and notoriety was that
he was a hothead yeah and that you know
their stories about him like you know
being really disrespectful and angry
with producers and and companies and so
that you know kept him away from bigger
stuff but he's still really big and
really famous and like I'm not I'm not I
legit mean it he's got a he's got a
video criticizing the media it's amazing
his Twitter feed is like free Assange
yeah speech stuff I was like it's
nothing like what I was he's an amazing
Lyricist oh yeah he worked with biggie
he worked with Wu-Tang he worked with uh
Mob deep so I mean he's been around for
a very long time but there there's a
video I mean he he's a good rapper man
he's good now if he wants to come out
and say he's better than Eminem and
stuff I just feel like it's a little bit
arrogant I guess but I mean
maybe he was trolling right or it's just
it's just the hip-hop you know stuff
like he's gonna you know create a beef
or whatever or whatever I don't know but
don't don't judge a person's talents
based on their opinion their political
opinions because I'll tell you this
Chris Evans has got a garbage bag full
of trash opinions in my in my view but I
think he's a I think he's a great actor
I thought he did a really great job and
knives out I like I thought the movie
was great a little woke but you know
still a pretty good movie and and and
you know I don't know we can separate
art from the artist yup right
all right let's grab some more of these
super chats here
Brendan does says the salty cracker is
being banned on Rumble right now if Dave
Rubin is defending rumble's recent
business changes ask him directly why
such a freedom-centered and outspoken
individual is being canceled this very
moment
Why is salty cracker being banned on
Rumble
I don't know that channel well well the
the I guess uh uh I don't know a lot
about the core substance of with their
views are I know that these uh the salty
crew they come in the chat all the time
and they're shouting them out and
everything like that but I I honestly I
can't say that I care
I don't think Rumble should be censoring
anybody yeah anybody yep
I don't know man let the law handle it
right let the government let them if
it's legal exactly if it's legal speech
allow it they're they're I think there
are issues about not having to promote
certain things like rumble's got a front
page where it's like podcasts and other
shows that they the editorial they
editorially you know promote I don't
think you're entitled to that I don't
think I'm entitled to that if my content
can be on Rumble and people can go find
it through the URL and search for it and
there's no Shadow Banning they don't
have to Market me but actively removing
stuff they should not be doing that
but we'll see we're we're uh we're we're
talking with the with the guys over at
Rumble maybe we'll have um someone from
the rumble Team come out here and do a
show with us and talk about all this
stuff I think that'd be very great and
we have some ideas look uh Rumble is a
net positive a huge net positive
everything that's going on with rubble
is is great it's good I just feel like
it's short term not a long-term solution
and so I'm worried about it and I think
I will say this too as far as it goes
with Rumble the criticisms that I've had
are mostly about
what might end up happening to Rumble
that is bad for us but I will say
everything happening now is is is a net
positive you know competition for for
Silicon Valley and all that stuff is a
good thing
all right Derek Watkins says Senate
version of the ndaa change section 716
allowing natural immunity and section
720 allowing General under honorable
conditions meaning military members can
lose GI Bill education benefits whoa
see this is what I thought this is what
I thought Tony Gillard says Luke is a
JoJo fan I'm offended and amazed I
definitely need that shirt I thought I
thought it was an anime reference no no
it's it's a very deep reference to the
politically understanding if you watched
this show we made a reference to uh this
you know JoJo saying and you really got
to be deep in the weeds to understand
this one so this is a carefully curated
shirt for the people who are in the know
really now says it wasn't the argument
he's he uh he drove me nuts he provided
no sources they didn't like the way he
spoke but I don't I
he had a Brooklyn accent whatever yeah
well one well I'll tell you this well
not I'm gonna leave it there I I don't
want to beat a dead horse I'm gonna be
saying the same thing I said already
Ashley Parish says Tim cast IRL is
becoming popular here in Houston suburbs
had two different cars pull up next to
me tonight with it blasting from their
speakers wow that's crazy it's so weird
to be on Twitter and like I was trending
Nationwide and I'm just like I don't
like that vosh had a really funny tweet
uh it was a meme where it was like I
can't remember it was a meme where it
was like I fear nothing but there's one
thing that really scares me and then I
like he you know whatever that Meme
isn't it pointed to it said trending
vosh and I'm like I know that feeling
yeah like I don't want to know why
people are why I'm trying to what are
they talking about I didn't even see the
re stuff until like a few hours ago and
so when I like woke up and saw the
message from Liz I can come on and I see
you trending and I see the clips I was
like it's a trap yeah I was like it's a
trap
no we were going to have Michael Graves
on but he couldn't come so we were like
who can comment such short notice who's
nearby or whatever the afterthought
Olivia yeah I was downstairs drinking
that's true yeah so Ian wasn't here
either and I was like who's available
right now we've got no gas and Ian's
gone too and then I was like oh Shane
you got a book yeah why don't you come
up and hang out shout out to Chris Carr
for these drinks awesome yeah we had a
Christmas party there was a secret santa
we went to a local pizza place and got
wings and pizza is awesome Chris Carr
who's the executive editor for
timcast.com made a bun he made the
Grinch the Santa and the Rudolph drinks
and it's all very heavy alcohol I can't
drink I tasted it and I was like it's
too strong and he edited this book
that's right yeah yep and art by uh
Jessica Jessica Boone that's right I got
a crazy gift by Jessica she gave me like
a portrait of me with a firearm cowboy
hat and glasses and this like crazy cool
like birding man like hat that's like
all weird I thought that was a 20 limit
uh yeah she said she said she went to
the Salvation Army she said she stole it
that's a Salvation Army like like
Goodwill or whatever and then she found
it there for for cheap and the picture
of the photo oh I see which is pretty
cool I was saying her labor is worth
more than twenty dollars oh yeah
absolutely she's great she does she does
amazing work did you post it yeah the
photo no not yet you gotta post on
Instagram
all right let's grab some more of these
here super chats I'll post it tonight on
Luke we are change
some Norwegian guy says you should have
gads sat on sometime isn't he in Canada
he is he has an open invitation but uh
we didn't want to do long distance like
a zoom yeah I don't want to do Zoom yeah
it doesn't it doesn't really work you
know yeah it is originally it was Iraq
it was going to be a vlog and then it
was IRL because we were doing like I
don't know in-person interviews or
whatever but we've never done remote
stuff I don't want to do remote stuff it
doesn't have the same feel it doesn't
have the same energy and Vibes I can
imagine yesterday's conversation over
like a zoom call I don't know it was not
there's no magic yeah yeah I did um I
was on Ben Shapiro's show I think it was
a Sunday special earlier in the year and
we had to record it because we don't we
didn't have that good event at the time
I recorded it and then I had to have the
memory card driven drive it somewhere
not not to bench Pier but we drove it
somewhere with internet so that took
like half an hour and then upload it and
then they basically took the recordings
and overlaid them but it wasn't the same
it was like there was a a I don't know
it just doesn't it doesn't work as well
yeah this is energy there's no energy
you know
um I'm looking forward to when we get a
chance we've actually been trying to
figure out um having Ben Shapiro come on
yeah because we are big fans and I think
it would be a really amazing
conversation but of course the dude is
one of the busiest guys on the planet
and you can't ask someone not to do
their show to do your show it just is a
weird thing but we are actually planning
on spending a week at the daily wire HQ
we were planning it actually in November
but we just couldn't make it work it was
very difficult and then we ended up
going to Austin because with you know we
had a week to build this mobile studio
and then by then the plans for for you
know uh for Nashville didn't make sense
but we're thinking maybe in January
depending on the weather because we
don't want to be driving a trailer
through snow and mountains and stuff we
might go to Nashville which is not too
far from here I think it's like nine
hours and then hang out just outside the
daily wire headquarters and do a
week-long show with the daily wire crew
and then maybe even if Ben's in town
have him pop in like Joe did and then do
another insane Tuesday episode where we
have nine people all yelling at each
other all the guys on the daily wire
that was great that that was one of our
biggest shows ever and I'm so uh it was
just amazing it was just ridiculous and
great
all right let's read some more
Ethan Randall says did y'all already
cover the sixth Circuit Court ruling on
vaccine mandate which one was that so
many rulings I don't know yeah I don't
know which one out of California I saw
that might be the one that reinstated it
I think I think they reinstated it
Gemini writer says would you consider
having Tom McDonald on the show of
course open invitation yes Tom's awesome
I've spoken to him a couple times he's a
rad dude he's a one a f yes exactly Tom
versus R.A oh no they're friends they're
going okay so I mean like in a talk oh I
mean that'd be nice to bait between two
I feel like that might help simmer
things down and get a real conversation
going too especially considering they
are friends yeah and and you know we
don't know where Tom is though on that
kind of yeah you know it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter the conversation yeah
great yeah Tom's rad amazing music but I
think I think you look at this Windows
music you kind of know where he is oh
you get him right but he kind of Rags on
everybody but he definitely hasn't been
good yeah that's what I like when I went
to Joe Rogan's show a couple years ago
he ragged on everybody and everybody
laughed Jonathan pie the Jonathan pie
show I saw with him and Andrew Doyle was
legit the funniest comedy performance
I've ever seen hands down I was I was
physically in pain if I'm laughing I'm
not kidding it was like man Andrew Doyle
is the the dude who does the titanium
McGrath Twitter the the fake woke oh
yeah it was so I saw it I saw him
perform in New York and the Beats were
just so on point that I was laughing
harder and harder and harder and then I
was like yeah it'd be awesome to have
Andrew we're going to oh as soon as we
figure out how to get them over in the
UK yeah everyone's trapped in their
countries man man I really want to get
Sargon too yes Sargon and Captain you
guys gotta come down both have kids well
they're talking about doing another
two-week lockdown in the United Kingdom
which is crazy we gotta get we gotta get
we guys we gotta plays come to Florida
New Hampshire let's start a new life
seriously Canada is part of the
Commonwealth or whatever you can just go
there right no don't go to Canada so you
don't want to go there well at least
once they get there then they can come
here yeah yeah flee New Hampshire
borders Canada look at this Logan
Doherty says I honestly thought last
night was one of the best shows thus far
although I was getting super heated it
was amazing content and a great
conversation a lot of people didn't like
it but it is our most engaged with set
member segment ever it's it it resulted
in this massive viral Trend I do not
pursue this kind of Jerry Springer type
interactions a lot of people are like I
got messages like if you pursue this rat
with these like you know rage debates
and I'll they're like you'll be so big
and I'm like no no we don't want
anything nope nope no thank you man no I
I never thought this operation would
grow to what it is right now I'm like in
my living room with a GoPro 4 second top
of my monitor and I'm talking about
thing for 10 minutes and that's all I've
ever been doing and then it just kept
growing and getting bigger and bigger
and now we have like 30 employees
there's a book on the Shelf written by
Shane edited by Chris drawn by Jessica
put together by this crazy amazing team
in this new studio now we've got a 7 500
square foot 25 foot tall uh building
being put together with a new studio and
I'm just like how did all of this come
together amazing it's crazy because
you're busy
but I'm just some of the hardest working
people here yeah I know it's true but
everyone here is how long did it take
you to get that book put together like
not outside of the writing outside of
the writing putting up like I talked to
you about this two weeks ago yeah we
talked about it when I first met you but
I did it in two weeks we were like two
weeks ago I was like it'd be awesome if
we can get a book done by Christmas and
you were like I can do it done I'm not
sitting right here yeah it's amazing
yeah yeah everybody's just working like
crazy man so it's really good but it's
fun it is fun I'm loving it super fun
all right we'll grab uh we'll grab one
more incar uh Incarnation art says Tim
love you man keep your head up would
love to see Viva Frey from a fry and uh
Rakata law on again that I pronounce was
both wrong and I would love to make it
on one day to talk about the perspective
of being mixed race and always being
expected to choose I hear you on that
one man yeah it'd be really cool to get
VIVA and raked on at the same time yeah
yeah maybe I don't know it's really hard
for um Aviva's in Canada so it's like
it's hard uh where's rakeda he's in New
York or where he's nearby he's okay sir
I think yeah that'd be absolutely
fantastic and Robert Barnes again too oh
yeah uh maybe maybe with the Kim Potter
trial or something like that we could
have like a legal round table or
something so uh you know we'll check it
out
and uh to everybody else thanks for the
super chats it's Friday nights we're
getting really close to the holidays so
smash that like button if you want to
support the show and this time smash it
for Luke Luke is sitting here and he
needs your likes smash that like button
because I don't need it but just really
quickly if you want to support a real
person of colors business you can give
me your money because if you're a white
guilt on Luke uncensored.com you could
also support me of course by just going
to enough of censorship.com people ask
what's the best way to support you
signing up on the email list is one of
the best things you guys could do since
of course it's not a part of the big
Tech so thank you guys so much for
having me on it was a blast it's fun I
always love being here for the
conversations and it's it's always uh
surprising that's great and awesome
don't forget go to timcast.com become a
member as well if you want to help
support our work directly you can also
go to uh and follow us at timcastirl and
of course right now type in open new tab
and type in invertedworldbook.com
and Shane can tell you all about it
first of all thank you for giving me the
opportunity
it's a dream I mean this is I I've had
so much fun I started this book on June
20th this year the first sentence was
written down the road right after I met
you that's so awesome and uh 275 Pages
275 Pages later I talk about simulation
Theory uh and ghosts that I've may or
may not have encountered reaching
through the simulation uh I've tracked a
serial killer in Long Island
which are uh third and final part will
air on Sunday morning on YouTube at 10
A.M it's also on Apple and Spotify and
uh yeah it's true crime paranormal
aliens people being abducted children
being taken out of their rooms so that's
invertedworldbook.com but you're already
getting started on the next book right
which I'm really excited for because we
already started it this this one's a bit
of just like a collection of tales yeah
but the new the next one is ghosts of
the Civil War which is murder
conspiracies lost gold UFOs yeah this is
like uh the age of covid paranoia and
parent and and the Paranormal stuff as a
going through it all you know because it
was it was just cool when you were
telling me about the people down there
and they're like anger towards Sherman
oh yeah I wore a West Point hat when I
went down there that's where I grew up
on a military base right and you know
all the all the Civil War generals came
from there so I thought it was a good
middle ground but the Sherman's a bad
word but it's but it's for people to
hear that and then to hear these people
the stories that like you guys got to
understand like the stuff I don't want
to spoil anything but some of the creepy
conspiracy stuff going on down there
related to this stuff is crazy we've got
a lot going on I'm in tunnels under the
city wow I got ground penetrating radar
looking for we got to get that one
skeleton I'm like the first one's out we
got to get that one out it's gonna be so
cool yeah no six months probably six
months next book yeah dude the Arts can
be fantastic and then I'm excited for
Loosely we're talking about this the
Chicago Mafia oh yeah ghost stories
Bachelor's Grove I'm gonna be so so
amazing you got social media on shout
out uh um Shane Cashman everywhere I
also co-host a podcast called Ready slow
with Sean strong and I have a members
only podcast I do in the old IRL studio
uh it's on timcast.com I do that every
that comes out every Sunday night and uh
check out the book invertedworldbook.com
yeah so actually there's on timcast.com
there's members only segments uh once a
week about these stories that you've
investigated so some of them are crazy
DMT aliens but we are actually putting
together an additional uh add-on to that
which I think I don't know how where you
guys are on that I think we're gonna
record it tomorrow like uh so it's you
and Chris Carr just generally talking
conspiracies a few of us we got Brett
yeah yeah so it's like a whole new show
actually yeah we're trying to figure out
how to do it because we don't want it to
like interfere with inverted world
because they're similar yeah but this is
the general conversation on just like
General mystery I think we're gonna come
with articles and we'll kind of discuss
like a round table a very specific thing
instead of me just kind of like spinning
like this is this is you investigating
stories and telling these stories and
this one is discussion of conspiracies
and Mysteries and stuff for sure it's
gonna be awesome man awesome uh Olivia
you got stuff you want to shout out
right yeah well I've been a Tim Cass
contributor for a few months I have a
new uh article coming out shortly I'm
waiting for Chris to get back to me but
it's basically examining the history of
uh racism anti-black anti-blackness in
the Democratic party how it affects
people today and why uh White liberals
feel comfortable taking away black
conservatives or black Independents
Blackness for their own benefits so that
should be out shortly I'm on all social
media platforms
o-l-i-v-i-a-r-o-n-d-e-a-u-n I also have
a baby YouTube channel if you guys want
to subscribe to that too it's under my
name as well sweet thanks for coming
thank you so much thank you guys very
much for tuning in for the newer calmer
version of timcast where we reflect on
our wild and crazy days yesterday it was
very fun and exciting we I feel like we
learned a lot and I feel like we had a
good conversation so thank you all for
tuning in then and for tuning in now you
guys may follow me on Twitter at Sarah
patchlets somebody said did you hear
Jack Murphy freak out on Sydney I'm
seeing those comments too what happened
I don't know but that's that's what no I
don't believe you I don't believe it
they both have some freak out it's
probably him arguing and it's like sure
I hope I don't know we need Sports and
mandates
I don't know we'll see all right
everybody we're gonna get out of here
have a good weekend love you jack merry
Christmas everybody if we don't see you
we're only gonna be doing Monday Tuesday
and Wednesday next week because Ian's
not here and Christmas Luke's I don't
even think Luke's gonna be on Wednesday
I'm not gonna be here and then I'm
leaving on Thursday yeah I'm out too
um yeah all right there we go merry
Christmas if we don't see it we'll be
back Monday thanks for hanging out we'll
see you all done bye guys